are
are we live we live through can you hear
us
it's our first time using streamlabs can
you hear us this is new
we need to know guys yes let us know
we need to know comment below
all right i need one comment that tells
us that we're live and then we are
good wealthy keep going guys can i see
here
oh yeah can i see here yes you can hear
us what's up tm what's up pj
gene jeter hey already got some super
chats today tm
trademark bernie alvarado electric
lizard hello mimi
josh ren accuracy ayla
um yeah so brittany lang hey so so you
guys know
um john you want to explain to them
because i mean if you guys super chat uh
that's okay
we prefer that if you do want to do a
super chat that you do it through
stream labs and the reason why is
because um
youtube will take uh like somewhere
between 35 to 40 percent of all super
chat earnings because youtube's earned
it
so they will take 35 to 40 of the super
chat earnings
yeah and uh we want to make sure that
as much as people are donating or
whether it be super chat for a question
or something like that
that as much of that will go to uh the
charity itself we are donating this
directly to
the donation center on the
blacklivesmatter.com website
so we'll be sharing the receipt once the
actual transaction's been made
yeah so i mean if you do super chat i
mean i suppose that's fine if you don't
want to go through the
the additional step but the preferred
method uh would be through
stream labs but uh yeah just open mic
today whatever the
whatever the [ __ ] we want to talk about
yeah whatever questions you guys got
we'll we'll make sure it's a fun one
today
and uh yeah it'd be fun to just do one
all for charity we'll we'll post on our
community page to
uh everything that has been accumulated
from
adsense super chat and but mainly
hopefully you guys will do it through
stream labs
and hopefully we figure them and by we
figured the system out john because i
put all
i was like i have an idea john let's do
a a charity live stream it's about time
because
through the bail bale project um we
already
uh through you guys and not us even
really promoting it just featuring it on
certain videos you guys have already
raised
uh 2 500 so thank you guys yes
seriously like it was i didn't know what
i expected because we do have a decently
sizable fan base boom to see that level
roll in just off this little button i
was like oh this is cool
like hell yeah thanks yeah it's
inspiring to see thanks guys i really
did appreciate it
um if you guys want to hit one of the
voting buttons because i already saw
some people
wanted to have fun hit the dislike
button right away like all right
not even live yet they're just mad over
the concept of this
hey man some some folks are just not
down for the cause
or don't believe the cause even exists
but it would mean a lot if you guys did
at least hit one of the vote buttons
preferably the like button obviously uh
that because it just shows up more
people's uh
view count algorithm it just helps helps
out with getting this stream
seen but awesome all right
uh thanks trapdog i really appreciate it
and for streamlabs there's a link in the
description box a link in the pin
comment you just go click
there and i believe it should just pop
up on our end right that's the way it
should go it should pop up in this
little menu here
yeah we'll see we'll see we're testing
the link right now just to make sure
verified i'll look you there we could
donate to ourselves if we wanted to
let's just do that make ourselves look
better yeah yeah i mean i've already
been donating here that would actually
be counterproductive on this and we
could just donate directly yes
even the point of today's livestream um
but yeah why don't we just go off right
now let's go with the super chat
john show them the new feature that we
got here ooh all righty let's see let's
see
i'm just gonna do i'm gonna take away
this uh so be a slight work in progress
and we'll have a smooth live stream in
just a couple minutes
so who's our first who's our first
candidate first candidate
is jean jeter tv life
is life is life so real and deep
lol thank you so much jean jeter
appreciate you
uh supporting to the cause our handsome
black man
from new york you like frank i was i
want to say friend and i said man i was
like black fram
yeah black fram yeah well you know i
mean like fam is a term of endearment
now yes so uh you know you're but uh
gene
i love you because you are both deep
and real yourself he's a wacky
[ __ ] that one
he's an interesting cat but jean jeter
does his own thing and i like it
hey and if you guys i mean we we would
love for you guys to donate to the
campaign but
you know like there's no need for the
comments of you guys being like uh we
can't super chat
that's fine i mean the adsense
accumulated from this is all going
towards
uh charity as well like the the videos
that we actually put the fundraiser on
video did not have adsense on it yeah
yeah
like uh we're doing whatever we can
right now and then all right what else
do we got here bernie alvarado
bernie bernie oh man not getting that
nomination
what do you say hey guys how's it going
my favorite song
by nat king cole is those lazy hazy
crazy days of summer
from the 60s when i was out protesting
in the civil rights
what's your favorite all these songs
favorite oldies
songs huh hmm let's see i mean
this is it's weird this automatically
gets filtered
and i it's this isn't my favorite oldies
song but you brought up nat king cole
and for some reason whenever i think of
like old time music and nat king cole my
my mind goes straight to the christmas
song yeah cause his version of the
christmas song like there is no better
like there's none better but uh i'm
gonna have to think on this i mean
moonlight serenade is always one that i
i pick for you know when i need to kind
of you know get classic although that's
not a vocal song you know but
i feel it today guys today's gonna be
one of those streams where we spend
way too much time per question
that we decided to take on today yeah
yeah yeah so
um baby i'm yours that's a good oldie uh
that is a good one my girlfriend in the
chat olivia st
under the boardwalk under the boardwalk
all right for sure for sure
i would listen to this song all the time
that's baby there
ain't no mountain high enough
70s count as oldies because that song
that the four
tops did for the shaft i think it was
like shaft in africa or one of those
shaft movies is a badass jam
i saw i wasn't listening to the oldies
station not long ago
[ __ ] eminem came on the oldies
station
what was
i mean it trips me out enough turning on
like klos or any of the classic rock
stations and hearing like red hot chili
peppers and like
the white stripes and i'm like oh damn
now everything we like is turning classy
yeah
or at least grew up on oh we got some in
there oh i'm seeing a lot of you guys
going to the stream labs thank you guys
so much for doing that
so so much we're going to try and we're
going to be popping around between
stream labs and super chats here
on uh youtube today so let's just do a
little bit of uh
mix it's okay if you can't yeah there's
other ways of showing your support guys
whether that basis means social
media you know if you feel comfortable
to go to a protest you know there's
there's many multiple ways you guys can
go show your support but thank you to
all who are donating to the cause
right now yeah as john tinkers around
i'll give you guys a couple more
all these songs um i really
love the doors uh my dad loved this one
people
are strange when you're a stranger
faces seem uh ugly or lonely with ugly
when you're alone
yeah when your faces seem lonely
when you're alone yeah that's the way it
goes there's a great one that's been
covered uh by the arctic monkeys called
uh
baby i'm yours baby i'm yours
baby i'm yours there's one of those like
duopi songs
uh i love this song acer said brandy
you're a fine fang this is gonna be the
whole stream
we're just gonna stay on uh bernie
alvarado's one question
here the whole time uh eric you're doing
double duty here i see right uh
here in the in the super chat but we're
going to the super chat
let's and then also going to the stream
labs here
i'm going to throw out let's see can we
do this now okay uh i'm gonna throw out
i might at least read back
from the uh stream lab super chats uh
here because we got one in from eric
i mean 50 bucks i don't know if i should
be like calling out people but
that's really generous of you and who's
the first one eric horseman
says black lives matter oh thank you
eric just straight up the cause very
much appreciate it
hitman hudson uh donated in pitched in
and uh
asks better film venom or green book oh
oh i would go with venom
i think i would probably i guess i
enjoyed it
objectively the green book is probably a
more solidly assembled film green book
did make me feel warm and fuzzy but yeah
i would watch videos i like them but
like i like both of them you know but i
would go with those
yeah i appreciate that hitman houston
mimi am just uh
donated in the stream labs one uh
five dollars thank you mimi yeah she
wants to know
what do you think about the help
becoming the most viewed
movie on netflix because of the current
protest
instead of 13th ava duvernay's
documentary oh okay
when they see us or malcolm x check out
for harriet a commentary channel on
youtube she has reviews on green book
and the help
ah appreciate you saying that yeah i
mean that's cool that the
i mean it's always awesome to say like
it's one thing about netflix weirdly the
comment that uh
uh comes to mind in terms of your
comment about like
can we remove the super chat uh menu
when there's
not there yes how do we do that we're
figuring this out in the moment
once we're at the 20-minute mark we will
have smooth sailing here on our trust me
sailing speaking of just quick really
quick
because you made a reference to queens
of the stone age uh
inadvertently and uh josh haami is on
the new run the jewels album
which is insane just just go go listen
to rtj4 it's free
all right okay so mimi
uh mimi m's question uh she said what do
you think about the help
becoming the most viewed movie on
netflix because of the current protests
right that was like the first part of
the question
what i find fascinating i think that's
hey that's a great thing um
b uh the one thing that i find
fascinating about netflix is it really
does
show you uh the influence of what's
going on in the world and how that
changes what we're viewing
because when the covid situation first
kicked in
it would like i was all these people
watching contagion i saw
outbreak was like numb like somewhere in
the top five
trending break was really true so people
are always some watching something like
within tune of what the
so it does go to show you that sometimes
you can't keep politics out of your
movie-going experience in the world
well and and the situation like that is
not political
yes it's it's scientific it's biological
just like uh this social movement i mean
not entirely political now i i don't i
wouldn't
i wouldn't say the help is the best
movie
for her for this i know it's been met
with some criticism
because of uh what's the quote i'm
looking for like why it's white savior
yeah because i was trying to think of
that war roasting the green book um
uh the white savior element to it so i'm
sure there are other films like
mimi m's bringing up uh ava duvernay's
documentary so i would encourage
more films uh such as that honestly if
there's a film right now that i would
recommend you guys go check out
if you are feeling inspired by these
times it's the movie blind spotting
that one it's like both really
educational
uh pivotal important artistic
entertaining but has but is one of the
best movies i've seen per
like i'm not i can't speak for you know
what a lot of black people think about
the movie
but for my beard experience i actually
think that was a very powerful
beautiful film uh but my favorite of the
of the year it came out i remember
saying that was my favorite of the year
it came yeah yeah
i mean i'm a little torn on it because
yeah i mean i think
like if it was green book or or
something
correct me if i'm wrong but the help at
least has you know some
uh it has like a black director at least
right because those are things too i i
you have to look further into because a
lot of movies about these issues are
written by white folks too
um so you know yeah it's one of those
things where i'm like
because the help from what i understand
is a
palatable kind of you know um i don't
wanna
it's one of those movies that you know
is trying to play to a wide audience i
think
yeah not white but wide and so um
yeah i feel like something like the
third uh 13th or
or you know something harder hitting i
would rather see
but i feel like if it trickles down and
it gets more people open to the idea
because those are the people who are
hardest to reach
you know maybe that's a good thing the
help is like the right step in
trying yeah it's like it's not what you
want it's like right there in the middle
it's not the answer you want to see like
you know if we were on
point you know it would it would be you
know something more documentary oriented
or something like that but
yeah i'd rather that than you know like
some
like the remake of uh death wish and i
heard i heard um
i heard the sam fallon in the in the
chat right now is saying just mercy is
also streaming for free
mercy streaming for free i haven't
haven't seen just mercy yet but i think
it's great that they decided to let that
stream for free
and the criterion collection right now
is uh streaming
uh all the black films in their catalog
for free you can go online and see all
those as well
um so there's i mean there is a ton
of black cinema history and the funny
thing is i was listening to the live
stream that um
that ben and jay washington and winston
and uh
rb3 and chance did and um
they were talking about how like black
cinema isn't just a genre
you know and it's treated very much like
it is and so um yeah i mean i think this
could be a cool opportunity for
everybody just who
loves art and movies to get this access
to the stuff and and you know
learn a little bit or or experience
somebody else's point of view but also
expand your cinema vocab too you know
all right well thank you so much mimi m
uh where's that
chat
that's the one they're all right here
for right now uh maybe refresh it
all right because uh you guys can't see
this but on
our end in the program we're streaming
out of right now it's ticking us and
showing
all of the chats regardless of where
they're going
john right now is coming off of an
anxiety state because i had him set up
everything yeah
and i did not help out once it's all
right
it's it's mostly just it's it's like
it's not
that hot hard but like they're just
inevitably these little things that get
frustrating and you're like why isn't
this working the way i was told it
should ah here we go we're getting some
updates in here
all right let's uh let's go in order
here kj
next kj uh over at streamlabs so guys if
you want to
if you the preferred method if you guys
want to donate uh would not be through
super chat but if you decide to do that
uh that is fine it's all appreciated but
stream labs there's a link in the
description box and pin comm and make
sure to
vote like or dislike button whichever
one you want preferably the like button
if you support these
obviously and yeah just a reminder that
the streamlabs link less will be taken
out for
fees and stuff by the platform yes yeah
so kj says love you guys did you see
becky just hit streaming yesterday kevin
james is the villain and it's a fun
slasher effect he's really good as the
main villain
villain not amazing but really enjoyable
haven't seen becky yet
i mean uh the idea of kevin james doing
a villainous role sounds very silly to
me but i always love a good turn i
always love
watching uh when a character who's very
much type cast is one thing
takes a major turn especially in the
comedy realm when you could do
that because it's i mean it's a much
bigger leap like
adam sandler going from comedy to drama
who's a really close buddy of kevin
james
going from comedy to drama is is one
thing but if you were to tell me adam
sandler playing villain i would
even me today who loves dramatic adam
sandler would be like
i don't know about this
so there's that oh yeah i mean i've seen
the image
i haven't seen the movie but i listened
to the double toasted interview and he
does look scary because he's got the
like big beard bald guy
look yes and uh you know it's
funny enough for me there's something
about the the critical it factor that
kevin james is not
quite as gargantuan a presence as adam
sandler that i am a little bit like
maybe he could do it you know there's
like i don't know why i slightly
believe that more but i don't know um
let's see here thank you kj for
supporting the cause hitman houston over
here uh over at streamlabs is a
two-parter then we're gonna move back
over to the super chats that you guys
put over here
um hitman houston says has
either of you seen network 1976
i saw it last summer and i think it's
the greatest film ever made
that is helen i'm not gonna take it
anymore yeah we've seen it i haven't
seen it since i was like
13 years old it's been several years but
it's a great movie i remember
really liking it it's very telling i
don't remember it that remember like
fate don't away i don't remember much
about it
wait did i get that right it's already
done away right how did you ever get
far the movie should be slow down
i remembered it being good that should
be a new category was this movie
good or bad i saw it in some class um
and then his follow-up question is um
uh any advice on how to get a girlfriend
asking greg in particular because he
seems like the expert on this department
just kidding i'm sure john has many
lovers
well funny enough you're not far off on
your commentary
i'm better at that and john's better at
that that's the way it goes
i don't know i mean it's all subjective
man i would just say
uh catch lightning in a bottle hey baby
can you are you listening
can you come in here i need advice
and can can you bring my toppo chico
from the freezer
you just go get your toppo i'm not i'm
dedicated to the stream
i need advice on how to get a girlfriend
don't ask her well i mean she she feels
she's been dealt
back what caused you that's how she got
what what did he do to coerce you into
this stockholm syndrome
i was drunk there we go
you heard it here get get drunk i was in
the new town alone and scared and he
prayed upon me hang in a
greyhound station that has a nearby bar
no uh he made me laugh
dude and now she's stuck because of the
covid situation
and no one else is allowed to make her
laugh and he mentally abuses me
and if anyone makes her laugh i [ __ ]
punch them in the face in my mind i
would never say anything
thank you baby yeah you're free to leave
look all these people have already been
donating so much 188 bucks gone to
charity here through youtube
and then 64. through streamlabs and then
through the bailiff project 2500 raise
on this channel alone
so you guys have been showing so much so
much important
love right now thank you guys so much
first one to donate
500 greg we'll show you his nipples oh
oh yeah nipple chills yeah all right can
i can i bribe you to bring me my topo
chico from the top shelf of the freezer
i brought you coffee
all right john this is the payment how
do we go back to
all right here we go get ready i'll show
you so we're gonna hide this title
overlay with the little eyeball
we're gonna reveal this with the little
eyeball and hit transition
all right for those of you watching at
home all right
so we got brittany lang just chiming in
to say hello guys hello canada thank you
so much for contributing brittany
thank you bro did you change your
profile pic again damn right she did
until
baby always changes her profile baby
every single livestream baby on it
all right who we got here currency
accurency
thank you i love you you guys
are awesome no you are because you just
contributed
to the right things you did have you
guys went to the protest where you guys
live i live in dc
and we'll be going later tonight again
stay safe and really great that you guys
are in this live stream nah man thank
you so much
uh be safe out there tonight during the
protest
uh yeah i went to a protest there was
one
my girlfriend went to one uh in la
and um it got broken up there was no
looting or anything happening
but cops started firing uh some like
weird gas
the [ __ ] like it wasn't your uh it
wasn't exactly
it wasn't tear gas but it was something
they just started firing in the crowd
and everyone started panicking
but there was no no nothing happening i
wonder why
there was like plenty of people there to
back up her story
and then um on we went to the one
on together the next day at long beach
it's very important you still stay safe
guys so bring hand sanitizer with you
wear gloves if you can wear a mask
obviously be as safe as you can um
imagine that we didn't stay
super late there was still a curfew we
wanted to get home before then
so but we were there for a few hours and
it was a beautiful thing it was like it
was honestly a very beautiful peaceful
protest
and it makes such a difference when
you're actually there
and feeling the uh the passion
of it what's been annoying me right now
like i don't i don't really put my
opinions out like i'll retweet a lot of
stuff
i don't really put my opinions out on
twitter because i feel like
it's a really hard place to have a
dialogue so what i'll do
is i'll start really no i found that it
is
there's a certain limited amount of
characters and you can't hear the tone
of voice yeah
who needs a tone who needs body language
so what uh what i
um what the only thing i've actually
said other than the fact that there's a
peaceful protest was like the main thing
that's been kind of annoying me as a
late
is uh jake paul [ __ ] that guy no it's
the uh
it's the fact that people are um a lot
of people who aren't involved in it are
not really getting educated on it
there's a this misconception that
it is like that that the
what i said was vast majority of
protesters
and this is not only my experience going
to that protest
it's just a fact the vast majority of
protesters are not people who are
looting or committing acts of violence
plain and simple they're not but because
the way the media likes to spin it
because the way people are interpreting
it is that everyone's going out there
and causing
when majority vast vast vast majority
it's peaceful protesters well yeah and
you wouldn't you wouldn't have all these
people out taking advantage of the
situation and looting
if there weren't already people in the
streets who really cared about this yeah
which is
the frustrating thing i mean the looting
isn't the point and there is something
to be said for the fact that we treat
property
with a lot more care than people in this
country but at the same time
uh yeah i don't think you would see that
if there wasn't a huge
issue going on that you really need to
look at in the main chat there's a lot
of love here for
the films get out and john boyega
dude yeah john boyega man i'll never
forget this was one of my favorite
comic-con experiences ever i went with
uh our our friend aaron
who used to do the dank ass stubs
podcast way back in the day with me um
we went
like we went down for like a day or two
and um
uh we saw attack the block it was like
the only screening we got to go to
and it was like they were just
premiering it there or something you
know
like it wasn't out and it wasn't big yet
and uh john boyega and joe cornish were
both there and john
boyega hung out afterwards and talked to
us and
on one of my like old android phones i
have a picture of the two of us together
and i
you know back then i mean it was his
first movie and everything and so it was
a pretty just sort of like
we were all excited to meet each other
sort of interactions but like
nowadays especially and having gotten to
see that movie
before anything happened to it you know
was was so cool
and just like and that's why i like you
know say what you will about the recent
star wars
movies but i really wish they made finn
a better character because i'm like give
my
like moses deserves better we're talking
about finn
sucked in force awakens but got great in
the last jedi
that's right guys that's what finn got
good and and you see him out
doing it he gave this great speech and
i'm like you know
this should have had something to do
with finn's storyline in the movie
like like like look at that finn should
be waking up storm troopers and like
like that point we watched in one of
those videos about like oh
but we're just gonna go wantonly kill
storm troopers anyway yes i was like oh
there could be more nuances here
i mean okay here we go uh what else is
in the chat here what else we got the
agoraphobic
fanboy sending support and good vibes
from ny there we go we stand in
solidarity also my fiance gave me a
corona cut so paul is
paid is paul's bald for now oh oh sorry
about that
wait so wait did you get like a bad
haircut
and you're like um my fiance [ __ ] up
my hair
i need to just shave my head is that
that would happen how did she take
that i'll answer right now
this is not a rhetorical question i'm
going to wait in the stream
btec bradford uh i've heard a couple of
people shout this out the only reason
i'm going to call any attention to this
right now
is because of charity uh
this uh this t-shirt this uh they live
stay awoke t-shirt all the proceeds from
this are also going towards the movement
this design
uh so if you go to london 18 just google
london
london 1888 and yeah if you like this if
you want one
it goes all the proceeds toward the cost
so yeah
and i'm wearing a batman shirt because
he liked to expose
the uh corruption
yeah and that's why he had to work with
james gordon because james gordon
couldn't do it from within the system
he had to go outside the law to make
things right
oh i've justified my shirt to be just as
powerful as yours john
there you go it's perfect um let's see
here who else we got here tyler hague
thank you so much for
donating buddy appreciate that bud eric
horseman we know we thank you eric
i love eric's left like he left a 50
chat here he's left more in here
wow man there's a lot a lot of people
chatting uh contributing right now on
streamlabs thank you guys so much
gonna have to repeat this throughout the
stream just to be safe
you know you can super chat if you'd
like to make you know life easier but if
you're willing to take the extra steps
that way
more of the proceeds do go to charity
would highly recommend you donate
directly through the streamlabs account
inside of our um description box and pin
comment because
youtube super chats uh youtube collects
35 to 40 percent
of whatever you super chat where a
stream labs not as high of a percentage
take
but it's still fine you're still
donating for the right cause so thank
you
uh let's see here electric lizard
i'm only he's thank you for your
donation dude i'm only 14 so i can't
protest but i can donate well you're
doing what you can
and be safe out there buddy really be
safe thank you for
for donating while you can dude dead
i-616
what a major contribution thank you so
much dude he said the best way to
predict the future
is to create it abraham lincoln that's a
beautiful quote beautiful quote
that's like law of attraction that's
vision that's goal setting that's tony
robbins [ __ ] right there
the real first tony robbins abraham
lincoln
i mean i don't know first les brown
abraham lincoln there you go
yeah i feel like les brown probably has
a couple less controversies under his
belt
probably yeah oh thank you so much uh
three dollar bill y'all uh
we love the double toasted guys so yeah
welcome i appreciate you
thank you for coming over um
so many people in here yeah 2020 uh i
feel like a beautiful thing can come
from this movement though what i think
is great about the movement
is that it's not just like i'm seeing
people going back and forth in the chat
obviously as expected um i just hit this
button john uh
let's see what do you want to do next
this is going to be the super chats for
now
and we'll come back to them in a bit
close the eyeball in transition all
right so yeah the
the thing about uh what i think is
beautiful about this movement is that
it's like we were alive during when the
rodney king thing happened
ronnie though the riots and uh
that was like primarily an la thing like
of course this was a thing
covered worldwide but it was primarily
an la thing and then
this is like sweeping the world right
now and i think it's so beautiful that
some people are banning together
and going out there and protesting so
this is this is like i think it's
amazing what's happening so there could
be good that comes from this granted
there's been a lot of shitty [ __ ]
things about 2020.
we're only in goddamn june i know every
like yeah it's literally like every
month has a new weird thing
i saw a great movie somebody
photoshopped of a shark seagull
and it looked so convincing for a second
that i was like yeah probably
why not 20 20. but i do like the thing
that
arguably has been getting me through
most of these weird situations
from our crazy leadership to
covid to this is in a weird way i've
started to feel like life has some kind
of writer's room because these things
are all
very uncanny and in a time where we've
been talking heavily about
the value of health care the value of
living wages and the value of you know
cultures and human life we've had a
bunch of events happen that have forced
us to stare directly at those things
whether or not we care about political
candidate debates and stuff so i feel
like
there is definitely huge potential for
learning and for
for good things to happen through a lot
of this
[ __ ] because you know if you're going to
make true improvements you're going to
have to pull out the toxic
you know you're going to have to pull
out the poison you know
got to upper root yeah yeah every once
in a while i'll have a word that john
doesn't have gotta ask
um we want the jazz back okay uh
let's go back to the uh let's see who's
contributed so far in the stream labs
all right he looks cool john's moving
there thank you guys for everyone who
has contributed so far
uh let's see here and if if you're just
joining in appreciate you being here
seeing just martin s and stella just
came in here
uh i would say uh if you can vote on the
like
always button please helps more people
see this right now
you were baking coffee cake erica's
baking coffee cake hey erica
i hope you baked enough for everyone the
window is loading but soon we will know
all the other people who have
contributed to the uh stream labs
account
yeah awesome yeah all right
there they're having some trouble
loading okay here we go
we're actually having trouble loading
because so many guys are donating right
now and
we really really appreciate that the
kind of problem you want to have
yeah i mean it's a good problem to have
this is the trouble
reloading the the questions that you
guys have put in there
only because so many donations have been
coming in
so it's doing a major update process
right
damn but yeah man to help you got and
also in terms of like
making a stream you know make sure to
keep asking questions and stuff too
all right here we go let's see oh okay
bur
uh bernice panders bernice panders
donated five dollars
um says uh i miss you guys both reacting
to the corridor cgi react series and
really want to see if you do the one
featuring
zach king's magic it has been a while
since we covered a corridor recruit
video
and they're cool with uh you know like
fortunately most of the channels that we
react to regularly are cool with us
you know covering their channels uh so
you know i
i i feel like we ought to get back on
the on the corridor crew chain so thank
you for reminding me about that bernice
i will never uh deny the opportunity to
jump on the corridor
you were we were both fans of the
quarter crew before we started reacting
to them that's usually how a lot of this
goes
you know it's weird because it's it's
there are a lot of things that i love
on youtube or what the things that i
followed that i've like found in the
middle and corridor crew was one of the
ones where i can look back and
go oh no i remember when i first saw
episode one of of at least that series
pop-up
yes um and then we got eric again
oh is this a different eric or is this
eric horseman
uh no it's a different eric i think
unless it's a different who no just an
eric right yeah i think i know it might
be horsemen
unless you changed your handle from eric
was here to eric
don't worry guys i i got i got the
jurassic guy handled all right don't you
guys worry
is somebody we're okay somebody's
spitting foolishness oh yeah
so here we go um eric is saying uh
trying to think of a question but brain
is dead from the week so just donating
again i'm glad you're
you're donating brother it is horseman
because atlanta had a pretty peaceful
protest today in atlanta
with one clash guess who started i
i can imagine so we'll be safe out there
eric you got to look out for your health
buddy
be safe out there be safe b thank you
for donating dude
the nikki lutzy thank you so much
donated 50 bucks
bill y'all from the youtube chat okay
cool awesome
i just found you guys through double
toasted shmodown a few years ago
you guys are awesome black lives matter
[ __ ] yeah dude nice
that was that's like a double find yeah
i found it
yeah he watched the show down for double
toasted yeah and then found
us yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly that's
pretty neat to hear cross-pollination i
mean and that was i mean that's still
one of my favorite like you know
collab situations we've ever seen
because i was following spill like back
in
high school you know when they were
spill.com still so yeah that was a
such a dream come true yes it's such a
fun match we removed jurassic room guys
um he can go through the trouble of
starting a brand new account
he can go join us to try to hate just
some art in this chat
he can go join the jurassic fight i love
the idea of a guy wasting his time
that much hey man i'm mad that i can't
talk in the light
and let me go and well he should try to
we once had to
create a new account we once had a guy
on our cameo account who was buying up
shout out after shout out just so that
he could tell us directly
how much he hated us and uh if you got
ignorance to spit
do it in a super chat because at least
then we can turn it into something
hitman houston um one i mean uh
one one great thing about setting up
what i wanna say really quick one
thing about setting up because we set up
the uh
charity for the uh bail bail project
over
on uh several videos that were monetized
because they were new and then we were
able to
it hit me with the idea that we could
also because we don't
actually get it's like it says that
there's ads running but we don't
actually get adsense from that
so what we did was we moved we also
added them
on because it hit me in that moment when
i was talking with john that night like
oh we could also
one thing you'll hear reaction channels
often complain about so if there's any
reaction channels that happen to come
across this moment i would really
recommend doing this
um one thing reaction channels will
often have an issue with is
you know come over do [ __ ] reactions
we're gonna we're bound to have
demonetized videos
copyrighted there's some advertiser
friendliness issues
yeah so we're bound to have those kind
of issues so i was like
well [ __ ] there's still so many videos
one so i spent like
quite a long time going through a whole
bunch of videos i was like is this still
getting views
but it's not monetized we could add the
charity there we could add the charity
here so i was like hey there could be
some
some benefit from the videos that aren't
monetized
you can at least have the charity going
up there as well yeah
so i've done a reaction or if you're a
youtuber who has videos that are
demonetized but are still getting views
i would
slap a charity on there you know i'd
recommend it
hitman houston over in streamlabs says
what is the best small performance
um the best small performance in the
film
my vote goes to algae smith and the hate
you give
i got and uh josh mccooga and enchanted
very nice yes um best small
performance that's a great question and
also a thinker yeah
best small performance my goodness
there's got to be a
one that like do you i'm curious in the
chat do any of you guys in the chat have
like one that's like a really tiny
performance
that truly stood out to you one can
argue
what's that who's like who there's like
a performance that got nominated for an
oscar who only had like
10 minutes of screen time those exist
did michael parks get a nomination like
that or something
i'm not sure i mean he does agree like
the problem is i keep thinking of
tarantino
movies like my first thought was
christopher walken and i don't think
that's like one of the
i i wouldn't reach for it as one of the
sentimentally best
but um but there are lots of like in
kill bill volume two
right the other character michael parks
plays for that one scene i was like oh
that's a great scene
john rocco assault soul score jade
nintendo says john roca and wind takers
talkers less yes um
[Music]
martin freeman in the hobbit
oh oh um one that always comes to mind
because i
uh the question if you guys are just
tuning in what is the best small
performance in the film
um small performance in a film from
hitman houston um the movie world trade
center
there's this this scene in the hospital
where
nicholas cage's wife is uh she's
standing next to some woman she's never
met and she starts to like
open up about oh man i'm gonna start
crying just thinking about it right now
she starts to open up about like uh
where her son was when the
when the terrorist attacks occurred and
uh
you know like just some she starts she
gives us monologues this random
character appears just a stranger i
don't think she's even has
a name in the scene and then she starts
to cry
it's her first scene in the whole movie
and i think the only scene she has in
the whole movie
um i wish i knew who this actress was if
you guys have seen the movie you
probably know who i'm talking about
and i'm in the theater i just start
bawling at this one like
first scene and i'm already crying and
there were one scene in the movie
uh yeah that was a great one and i also
shout out tim wings in the chat
brad pitt and deadpool too that's a
great one right there
um vanisher i believe is that
character's name
yeah there you go catch me on an
upcoming inner geekdom match apparently
apparently who knows all right john so
uh in the meantime i'm going to refresh
the stream labs one why don't you bring
us back to the super chats here on the
year
super chats so guys make sure to uh
yeah i mean if you want to donate you
can do it through uh super chat directly
or go to the stream labs account all
proceeds going to the black lives matter
uh donation uh section
like right there that's where i've been
donating just go to the what you can
just go to the website directly if you
don't care
for like get a question answered or
something but all right
who's next on the agenda johnny so after
the agora
boy we got our boy tyler hey guys
i love you we reread that one john i
didn't
john i'm asking you to keep up with
everything and don't have one single
misstep during this livestream all right
we're doing this for charity
this is an important one don't [ __ ] any
of this up john eric tipped to let us
know that he donated on streamlabs
we already did that one we already did
that okay
john you're messing pandemic jones is
here pandemic jones
pj surprisingly hard to think when
you're doing that like i'm sitting here
going yeah it's really obvious oh
especially with your anxiety and then
when you get stressed out and anxious
and how you can't think straight yeah
oh it's so fun to [ __ ] with him pandemic
jones is here
i re-watched straight out of compton due
to the events going on
loved the movie and how they portrayed
what was going on uh what they went
through back then
b-l-m oh dude yeah paul gmod
woo that's like the first thing you
people go through right after that one
well that's what always
that's what disheartens me in a lot of
movies where it's like oh you have a
black lead but like the white
supporting role is a bigger actor so now
you've got
robert pattinson in the thumbnail or you
know like not not to use that
tenant as like a direct example but like
there are there are examples like that
and it always bums me out
um yeah i would i would um
oh god uh straight outta compton that's
a long ass
did we watch that together yeah that's
right when we got back from mexico
yeah i don't even know why we put it on
we had a
i don't know yeah usually we only watch
movies because there's a purpose behind
why we have to watch a movie nowadays
um or unless you just get hbo max and
you put randomly put on green lanterns
they're like [ __ ] it never seen green
lantern uh
was it related to some kind of like
movie fights question or something
i can't remember um we did watch it like
the day we got back
oshea jackson uh he's what i thought was
awesome about that movie
was it spans so much time and some
people think it goes a little too far
and there are some other like
biopic moments where you're like i'm
sure that's how that conversation went
down
what are you gonna call the label
aftermath or
like this is my friend snoop dogg not
really necessary to be in the movie
but he's here now yeah it's bio-picky in
ways biopics are
but i think i love i honestly did not
know like of course i've heard so many
of their songs over the like i grew up
in
i'm we're 90s kids so i've heard so many
other songs but i did not know the ins
and outs of any of that story and yeah
i've looked up like the facts and stuff
but yeah there's um uh that's that's
actually i i really love uh i thought
that was a really great film actually
all right and i think a lot of people
weren't so sure about that one but when
it came out people were pleasantly
surprised by how good
straight outta compton actually was yeah
yeah
there's i've heard some debate around it
but i feel like the general consensus is
a positive
is a net positive uh hey lb welcome to
the chat my dear hey love you guys
hashtag black lives matter thank you lb
for showing your support
yeah michael roy roy ball
roy ball i love you guys and i will
support you guys
always thank you so much loving us you
are supporting the black lives matter
cost so thank you buddy
you're supporting human rights uh
mukbang reviews you have a great channel
hashtag blm thanks for doing this do you
have any specific hopes for what the mcu
will do
so many rumors um yes
yes i got some mcu hopes that's for sure
let me go change my shirt to a marvel
show
really fast do i have to keep my hopes
realistic um
i would say um uh my hopes for the mcu
let's let's highlight the questions so
people know in case they come in what
we're talking about
hopes for the mcu um
how about this talking about rumors
let's talk about things that we've heard
so far
shane chi i hope it is the martial arts
action epic that we've been promised yes
where it's a combination of more
traditional kind of like matrix meets
um something more like gritty like raid
somewhere in between there but their
fight scenes
and i heard it might be a tournament
movie you know i won't go into details
in case any rumors have to be sure it
could be a little spoilery
um all those rumors about toby mcguire
possibly making an appearance in the
multiverse of madness movie or upcoming
spider-verse movie
i know it's like exactly mcu the
spider-verse stuff that's more mcu
adjacent
but i'm hoping that's true but on that
note tom holland appearing in a
post-credits scene of venom 2
i would love to see that uh as
well and uh yeah
young avengers why the [ __ ] not
let's make that happen too he's gonna
say do i have to keep my
my hopes realistic no man just do
whatever you want
i mean i i want marvel to start making
one-offs and start
really like throwing down like i i think
it makes sense that their main universe
should remain an
action-adventure oriented thing but like
throw down on some of your weirder
properties or do some kind of like
uh what do they call it it's not
elseworlds and marvel but you know like
do something like that and what if
sounds like it's gonna scratch that edge
a little bit but i would love to see
something that's you know feature length
or that's you know live action too
that's always what i hope for but yeah i
mean shang chi if they do something
that's like
even like enter the dragon esque or
something like that i would i would love
that i'm most excited for that because
it seems like it's the most
different that we have coming up right
um
so yeah i don't know i guess what i
would hope for uh in a more reasonable
set
is uh that they commit more to
the other genres they're going into and
uh
to maybe some more nuanced uh
storytelling approaches for some of
these conflicts because there's only so
many
like the entire world is about to be
swallowed up events that yeah there are
other ways to do really high stakes
yeah so i want dc and marvel to cross
over
yeah make it happen lego i mean it needs
to happen when
when like both franchises are just dying
like oh no we never thought this day
would come
only steven spielberg predicted this
they need but once it starts happening
that's when they cross over they need
this
robert downey jr comes out of the woods
at 85 years old
to verse michael keaton's batman is what
i
want we got people throwing out uh some
small performances in the chat here
some good small performances uh let's
see glenn close and hook
a lot of people say uh or glenn close as
part of the nova corporate guardians of
the
galaxy
oh wow yeah that is a small role isn't
it peter sarafinowicz in guardians
galaxy
oh even deeper cut john william hurt who
did he play in the star wars universe
who peter sarafinowicz i don't [ __ ]
know he's the voice of darth maul
william hurt a history of violence oh
yeah
oh yeah you're gonna stump me i know oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah what's one you wouldn't
know
yeah oh just pick one
i'm sure you'll find one i wanna pick
one tracy
i want to pick his blade this is what
john and i do sometimes we'll just like
quiz each other like
as if we're like schmodown knowledgeable
[ __ ]
uh okay what is ben mendelsohn's
character name in rogue one
krennic what's his first name orson ah
johnny
he's the winner of today's challenges
what is the other guy by play by
zhang wen i think is his name john wen
the guy who's not donnie yen oh okay uh
oh oh
oh oh wait the one who's in doctor
strange the character name
who plays wong no that's no who are we
talking about no
benedict wong plays wong
you're like the other guy i was like
which other guy wait what the guy in
rogue one
who is not done again okay for some
reason i thought we switched to mcc
what's the character's name oh damn
big guy
maldus um
there are a lot of great the other if
you're talking about small performances
too i feel like
i keep coming to tarantino flicks
because there are so many of them
and there's so many great like one-off
supporting roles and stuff like that
jessie pop welcome to the chat scores40
colin olive
zone uh all right cindy richter and kyle
gas
in elf oh nice so let's go back to the
stream labs here for a second
uh so far you guys have already like
helped helped raise
uh oh i that was a bad call i'm re
reloading
reloading it at the time of reloading uh
it's almost a three
i'll ask a random chat question and
random chat question
in between here's how we'll do this
here's how we'll organize this in
between
tips we'll hop between the super chats
the stream labs and then when a
streamlabs page is reloading
we'll just go to the regular chat
because we're reading the regular chat
the whole time while we're talking
but then we'll just take some questions
from there really quick so
first question favorite reactors hey in
the reloading
process we have surpassed three hundred
dollars on streaming exercises
i know i was about to answer a question
i know it's just exciting john when i
interrupt you
it's a completely different thing when
you interrupt me
i take it personally okay all right i
didn't mean to hurt your feelings
welcome to trumpville
you had a different idea no
favorite reactors um shay
uh
uh yeah [ __ ] tyrone magnus why the
[ __ ] not uh
i feel weird saying tyrone because he's
actually like a really great friend of
mine
and uh it's like just shining here for
like yeah
other reactors i want to take the
opportunity to shout people who like i
don't actually
know that well or don't know at all um
uh um oh my god who are they they're the
anime guys
uh the two white dudes oh um
oh uh you tell you told me to look them
up yesterday yeah
what the [ __ ] are their names and
they're not blind waves so uh blind was
great too
uh systematics
panic nerd god who are they they're the
two white dudes they cover a lot of
anime
and it's not like a [ __ ] unknown
genre to tap into but uh
you know it we'll figure it out i don't
know but there's like some smaller
youtubers too
that of like other reactors i'm tempted
to just do a video of like
hey guys semblance of sanity that's what
they're called
sanity is great uh shea of course
tinker jasso i really like master b is
are you still making vids master b it's
been a minute since i've seen you but
crazy couples pretty cool deadpool party
always makes me happy
react source cinema siblings i believe
is the name
of her she's a really good one the movie
couple our friends movie couple
and there's also a uh yeah this cinema
siblings is the name of the channel and
there's also
um there's this girl who mainly does
movie reviews uh she's like a really
small channel i don't know
nothing's loading right now but yeah
guys those are some great reactors out
there you guys should go check out uh as
soon as possible
and then you know geeks and gamers
but let's go back all right so we're
here at the in the
stream labs i think sean c does some
reactions too i'll throw him oh yeah
sean
absolutely does react yeah and funny
enough i've never really watched any
ksi's stuff but i was watching him
yesterday respond
to a needle drop review of his new album
and his reactions were really funny to
watch so
i might just go watch some ksi the
normies is a great one yes
absolutely normies are a great one
reaction tea time
uh reaction tea time i haven't seen
those faces in a minute but
they always make me happy ah let's see
here
okay all right let's go back to the chat
here
we at in the stream labs live stream
it's
uh we got club adventure hey kyle club
adventure is that who i'm talking to you
right
thank you for your 10 donation much of
love
from the netherlands everybody everybody
that's that's
don's comment ah wrong one
we right here oh my god collier club
avenger did a 50
one okay don i'm gonna sing everybody to
you later
hope this little bit helps thank you for
being such amazing advocates
for change uh you're right there with us
brother thank you for being here kyle
appreciate it i appreciate it i hope
you're kyle i think you're kyle thank
you dude
and then dawn uh he says uh sorry did
you wanna say something i don't know i
mean
we're not the best advocates for change
but you know we're doing what we can
we're we're we're we're part of we're
supporting we're throwing we're part
i recognize that there are people out
there who are much more instrumental
than i am
that's all i was trying to say it's not
a game of tops that's true
i am doing do what you can that's the
whole point of this
just do whatever you can all right that
is true but yes i've only been able to
go to one protest so far i have donated
my own money we're doing this to try to
help out
geez john i'm sorry
you know what go outside
okay just leave you to read these
comments
i want to be a ceo one day just so you
can tell i could be like that
it's the mug that's right out of here
you're a totally different person when
you got a mug
go outside stand outside would you
you're getting on my [ __ ] nerves
stand outside for the rest of this
meeting
we can see through the frosted glass
don't you dare move
um okay john what's your question
much love from the netherlands everybody
everybody
yeah yeah i gotta go to bed john
sorry because it's around 1 48 a.m here
or p.m i always get the two confused no
it's a.m for if it's late at night then
it's p.m
a.m i'm glad you could be
here i'm glad you could be the whole
gate doesn't mean that in the chat by
the way i'm glad you could be here
uh at least right now to uh give a
donation so thank you so much don i hope
you get some rest
stay safe um mimi
i think are you are you like what are
you looking at john you're like really
focused oh sorry
are we frozen i was looking at the chat
um no i paused it
a while ago you put you pause pause that
one yeah oh oh
so we don't get echo and and you know
use up
stream you know bandwidth um let's see
here mimi back in our stream labs chat
says
um videos getting me through everything
um god i'm gonna butcher this
um hassan minh you know when people say
i'm going to butcher this
yes i'm waiting for the day where
someone says
i'm going to butcher this and then
someone gets really mad at them for
for his neighbor
you got to go in as well you got to go
in like it's a declaration
i'm going to butcher this you know
but yeah it's always like oh i feel
embarrassed i'm going to get this name
wrong for the day of like then why even
speak it you [ __ ]
uh hassan monhaj's we cannot stay silent
about
george floyd ooh we gotta watch that
yeah i've seen part of it it's good i
like his program
uh conan's interview with uh w kama bell
and amber ruffin's experience with
police on late night with seth
meyers uh can't wait for yvonne orgy's
hbo special tonight ooh gotta check that
out
i gotta catch up on insecure oh wow i
didn't think
i didn't know about the conan one no i
didn't get serious conan gets serious
man mr king live welcome to the chat
welcome
uh but thank you mimi m uh number
screenshot
because i will forget about someone
thank you mimi
ethan holgate john take it away
i'll leave i'll leave no john take it
away um
hi greg and john nice to see
what you're doing here with your support
just asking who are some of your
all-time
favorite action directors and movies of
there's my top three favorite action
directors are
john woo michael bay and james cameron i
read that with the
worst cadence ever but yeah some of your
favorite action directors in movies
uh his top three is uh yeah john woo
michael bay
and james cameron um
action directors i mean um this should
be my [ __ ] answer this should be this
should be my answer this is
this should be your time this should be
my time to be like oh guys
watch the [ __ ] out i got so many answers
and i'm like
why can't i think of anyone right i'm
sitting here like i know edgar wright's
not like an action director per se but
he can certainly
it's like john woo is a legend but like
i was asked a question
on a movie fights match of uh
what director should like if there was a
spin-off of john wick
what director should do it and i said
john woo
because you know with his like with john
wick being so much about gun fu
and then if he did that with john woo
bringing him back and maybe he can go
back to a little bit more of his prime
that would be cool because
you know john woo hasn't been the great
grant i haven't seen his latest films
lately
but um yeah we don't really get too many
who are some [ __ ] action directors my
god what is wrong with me
well no i mean that's the other thing
too is i think times have changed
a little bit i mean you could like
nowadays i'm sitting here thinking
chad stahelski and his part and david
leach
are the two guys who you know their
names when they're directing action
movies but we don't have like a john
mctiernan now or something like that or
you know
it's like you see i'm seeing stuff in
the chat of people right now who are
saying like john mctiernan uh soul
square j john mctiernan
michael mann michael mann um
but i mean the question is the question
about today i'm so hung up on the
technicalities oh your favorite all-time
action director okay good all right
i guess james cameron sure uh i mean
james can't you gotta give it to james
cameron because i don't view him as an
action director but he's got access most
of his films have action
even titanic i mean the way that they
film that boat crashes
is insane it's pretty speaking corridor
crew go watch their video about it
i mean in some ways yeah it's like what
eng
lee is not an action director but i love
the way he directs action
like didn't he just do gemini like the
only girl i was
incredible the only good thing about
gemini man was the action was insane
and he did crouching tiger and you know
i'm not the i'm not a big fan of his
hulk movie
2003. but i i also don't
really uh i can't i i don't
i i think i like the action in that
movie i think i've seen other angley
movies i love the action there
um yeah i mean there's a lot of love for
john mctiernan
is there something problematic with him
did he die no didn't he did he go to
jail
was he the one who who who like
vehicular manslaughter or something like
that
i feel like he went to prison for a
while for something like that but i'm
not sure i may have him also confused
with
another guy from that era who directed
showgirls
who directed showgirls uh verhov i i
can't
tell i don't remember if it's verhoeven
or mctiernan who went to jail but
yeah yeah i'm not sure and verhoeven is
another option there
this is one of those questions where
like a gazillion things are gonna come
to my mind
well the problem is i keep thinking of
individual movies and i can't really
trace like uh several movies by one
director or or a few directors where i'm
like yeah
so i think you do kind of got to broaden
out with like james cameron is a is a
good choice because he's also
adding action into other things
i mean michael bay is one of those
obvious answers for a guy who's that's
his thing
um oh god yeah i'm not sure um i don't
know if i would say my pawn is pretty
[ __ ] great too
like that's funny yeah i think i think
matthew vaughn has done a
quite an incredible job at um
doing like these crazy handheld [ __ ]
things that normally annoy people in
films now
but he does it with such you should say
paul green such style
you know yeah and i like and that's
primarily the kick
the the kingsman movies like kick ass he
held back a little bit
you know it's still still there but i i
do love the way he directs action
um yeah sure why not russo brothers [ __ ]
it
uh but anyway i spent so long on your
question thank you
uh daniel96j1 thank you for donating
buddy all he did was donate thank you so
much
thank you erica tuesday eric
erica i do terrible impressions of you
i'm sorry
uh thank you for your big 55 donation
here
she says hey guys thanks for hosting the
stream good on you love and miss you
both we will hang out in your jacuzzi
one day soon thank you so much for
donating those kovids
and jurassic room who i uh
i banned from the chat
maybe he has donated here on streamlabs
well let's see what you gotta say uh hey
man
uh my hey my bad i didn't mean to start
anything i know y'all are doing what you
think is right
also aussie david in grumpy old man it
was a small part but he was a good actor
ozzy davis yeah
well we have a difference of opinions
either way i'm glad
your donation despite you disagreeing
has gone
to a cause that we believe to be a good
one
yes i didn't get to catch all the things
you were saying before but i don't know
i mean at least
if we can go about this civilly that's a
nice thing i appreciate that
oh john i studied for the showdown one
hour a night
so i have gotten good at going
we got three different three different
comments threads going here
that are all filing in and i'm just
absorbing all them at once
that's what i'm doing you are the child
of the future you're gonna be that guy
i've seen him back to the future too
when they when like uh
[ __ ] marty mcfly jr is
like looking at the tv screen there's
like nine screens over there yeah
yeah yeah every channel possible
yes all right um
eric again says uh please tell me thank
you for donating dude please tell me you
have seen
boys in the hood r.i.p john singleton
john singleton
uh i saw boys in the hood a censored
version when i was a little kid on
television
that's the way to watch boys in the hood
right there
i have not i have not seen boys in the
hood i'm just gonna go on record i've
seen don't be a menace to south central
while you're drinking your juice in the
hood but that's a very different film
is it because that's what i was thinking
the waynes brothers they're instrumental
filmmakers uh no i
i definitely am gonna add that to my
i'll watch it over the weekend probably
yeah yeah cause uh because that that is
a pocket of cinema it's weird i've seen
a lot of like black exploitation stuff
um but yeah like i should catch up on i
want to do like a spike lee marathon and
yeah
some of that too but uh well john
singleton man yeah
rest in peace and peace man uh so the
so for anyone who's new who's chiming in
because we people every
stream people fluctuate in and out hey
if you've been here for a while make
sure you've hit that like button
b um all donations are going directly to
charity
uh directly to the black lives matter uh
what's the most efficient way to say
this
that like i just go to the donation
center of the black lives matter website
that's what i've heard is the best place
to go for this so um
and uh if you do super chat that's okay
preferred method that way
most of the donation
the higher percentage will actually go
to the charity because youtube takes 35
to 40
on youtube super chats
all right where are we green lantern
deadpool christopher mcquarrie
walter hill all right soups
get in the soup i really appreciate
everyone who's been donating guys
because so far on youtube
uh super chat 320 here on the stream
labs 392
on the bail lift project uh the
fundraiser we've been having going
2 500 so far so you guys have been great
is your mic
down john i said john's mic is down my
mic is down
it's it's giving me uh like reading over
here
all right so who's next here
it's okay silver don't worry um
no no silence in the chat well we can
have like a moment of silence
you know who made the greatest live
stream channel
reaction tea time yeah you guys seen
reaction tea time
oh my god do yourself a favor that would
be so good
if they were just like what if they can
get so many viewers just sitting there
you know if they did it live and they
really were there for like
hours four hours sitting there doing not
much
that would be great i would okay mike is
good we're good we're all right
all right here we go here james payne
james paige john you want to read that
buddy
yeah who do you all think is the best
actor director team up thank you all for
what you are doing
as a service member i can say that doing
this qualifies as serving your fellow
americans and country thank you
oh thank you man yeah thank you and
thank you i would say you being a
service member
is not good enough though buddy well
we're doing
way more than you should you make more
sacrifices and put yourself out there
more
yeah not as not as strong enough i
appreciate that james i feel like i've
seen your comments before sarcastic
humor
i'm all right not being serious
seriously thank you for all that you do
thank you james um favorite actor
director team
up like this i'm assuming it has to be
one we're like oh yeah these guys are
paired up together often
um pegan edgar wright i got a weird one
uh it's not weird but i don't think it's
like a go-to answer
uh vigo mortensen and david cronenberg
ooh not bad i i love the work they do
together
okay like eastern promises history of
violence we haven't seen those like
that they [ __ ] are great together um
i i i think that's it though because
we're like uh
i feel like there's one more isn't there
and i mean would you count like uh
dicaprio and scorsese yeah i mean
dicaprio and scorsese
tarantino and sam jackson oh yeah well
yeah yeah he's in most of his
films i mean because yeah he is and he
always shows up in unique places and he
always gives him a juicy role you know
i guess i would say uh
i don't know it's like there's hey
there's like de niro ends gus van sant
and no there's there's de niro
and uh scorsese and then there's like
dicaprio and scorsese
i guess between those two that's like i
feel like the
the logical answer of a subjective
choice would be de niro and scorsese
but i also think that like dicaprio's
career wouldn't be where it is
right now if it wasn't for
martin scorsese like like the departed
gangs in new york
aviator yeah um there's more wolf of
wall street
uh shutter island but i think the
departed was when like leo's career
really
flipped and he wasn't the boy anymore
like it wasn't like oh pretty boy leo
it's like oh damn he really he threw
down this boot
exactly intense he's like a man yeah
yeah i would say that one
um
no problem artemis doing what we can i
mean spike appreciate you joining
spike lee works a lot of the same people
too
i feel like he's yeah he's one of those
guys who's got a troop because then i
start to think like okay that you got
lindro uh he's worked with uh john
carlos mozito a few times
but i'm like who are like the the ones
we're like yeah you usually associate
them to be together
bruce campbell and sam raymond yeah
yeah yeah most definitely because he
brings
he brings bruce campbell where he goes
pretty much
um i don't know do you guys have any
who's like your favorite director
wes anderson and bill murray anderson
what's anderson bill murray and jeff
goldblum
jason schwartz tilda swinton and
everybody every everyone in those movies
and then anissa what's up girl anisa
what did she say john she said hello my
beautiful people
the beautiful people one of my favorite
movies is hidden figures a story about
three brilliant african-american women
doing amazing things
a nasa story i didn't hear before i
watched the movie
so amazing is so good
he stole the show stole the show
every movie that people list that stars
people of color
i'm gonna try to find the one white guy
to point out
let's see how often i can pull this off
right now agree
that's the way it's the way forward
that's a good movie though
i do i do appreciate that movie quite a
bit i haven't seen it
and uh it's funny too because for
donating i think that patrick h willems
or somebody maybe pointed this out but
it's interesting to
to to have movies like that that take
place around
different angles on the same historical
event because you have i think like the
right stuff
hidden figures is happening like right
at the same time so uh in that way
the universe is kind of all connected
and uh but yeah that is a really
important and fascinating story so
that's a good call
thank you thank you so much anissa for
oh i just thought of another good
director
actor combo because and i thought of
this you know why i thought of this
because people in the chat are talking
about it
i mean joined at tim burton um ooh
james cameron arnie yes but i got a
different one james juan and patrick
wilson
that's a good one somebody called out
the one i was thinking earlier michael b
jordan
and ryan coogler yes thank you yeah
because they always how did that knock
him to my hand that's such a great one
yeah yeah uh jgl is always in ryan
johnson's movies
not the last jedi
or was he a cameo a canto bite i feel
like he might have been
he's a storm trooper somewhere you know
it
all right uh thank you anisa and then
who do we got david gandy thank you so
much david gandy thanks for the lead
uh lead lead guys on this guys
what oh am i reading it uh let's see
here
thanks for the lead guys on this guys
the lead guys on this guys
maybe maybe it was like maybe this is
how you take this on the live stream and
make us look like
total morals maybe david was trying to
say thanks for the lead
uh maybe he was like trying to say both
sentences and then wrote both or
something or you know when you like go
back and re-read and you're like oh i
accidentally put the
fragment so i think it's like thanks for
the lead on this all right fair enough
yeah
no problem but you can also clarify
sylvester stallone and sylvester
stallone is a great writer that is a
great
director yeah ben affleck and ben
affleck for sure
and then uh we got nancy here my sweet
man man
is there a way to change the dimensions
of this no oh yes there there is
yes you can you it's harder to change
the uh
if we did that that way they the crop
but yeah
you can do that oh yeah let's hit the
transition button
yeah oh there we go yeah there we go now
we can see
more of the names clearer and i'm
messing this up guys
all the way you p nancy to others who
can't now they can't see nancy's name
this was a terrible idea well just
scroll up a little bit i
oh you have to scroll up oh john you
handle this
okay this is my this is where you come
in
okay so this is uh
all right this is where we want this
yeah just literally be like three
people's names
that way it's easier and that way their
names can be read better
i am gonna scroll upwards hold on one
second guys one second oh that's why
because there aren't enough that i can
scroll down that far
that's the problem here oh john maybe we
can put it at the top of the screen and
crouch beneath it
okay here we go so all right
we're only doing this for one two others
this is very uncomfortable so nancy says
to others who can't go protest chronic
illness here which
that's just real please take care of
your health remind
uh reminder there's lots you can uh do
donating volunteering from home
educating people speaking up very true
exactly very
true i mean you gotta you gotta imagine
nancy
there's a lot of people i'm talking
about such a serious subject
there's a lot of people um who have
gotten more involved who have been
influenced by the fact that they've had
friends or people they look up to have
been sharing on social media so yeah 100
agree with that
that assessment you got right there and
for a lot of i mean you know if you want
to be an ally
a big part of that from what i've come
to understand lately is helping to
just elevate the voices and the
experiences of my head's cutting off
black folks and people of color and all
that stuff so you know yeah
you share that yeah yeah
yeah dancing archer completely lost my
train of thought
archer
thank you so much truly truly uh archer
p is saying i want to thank you guys for
doing this i've had a rough
past two weeks with what's happening in
the world as a person of color and as a
fan of the channel since 2014 you guys
made my day um a little
say more horrible that's what i'm
reading bearable
oh man i was like this comment is taking
all the
trajectory i'm sorry we let you down so
badly
i thought it was papers man i was saying
is in our our limited vision it looks
like it's saying i wanted to make
you guys made my day a little more
horrible
uh but thank you so much archer pa
really do appreciate it buddy all right
john let's can out of here fan out
hey guys they're 340 here on the super
chats you guys have raised so far
currently at 422 on the on the
stream labs right now thank you guys so
much
all right what's next uh getting back to
the chat we're going to get
back or we can refresh the uh stream
labs too
see what the prog is greg alba and john
humphreys because we all know greg is in
charge
greg in charge i'm not in charge ryan
wright's in charge
yeah just work for him he collects the
paychecks
we work for steven youtube
and he is hard to get a hold of and very
mercurial
especially when designing his product
uh let's see here john should be the
next shaggy
and scooby-doo oh man
all right i would do that i i would be
down i would have fun with that
oh wow you guys have been so great to
this all right let's see here
okay we going up we going up
erica jurassic room eric all right
hitman
hudson john take it away you all heard a
rumor that you all have a cameo in the
upcoming
small independent film the eternals and
by heard
a rumor i mean i started a rumor is this
true
yeah i'm playing um stephen eternal
what are their family names in that
goddamn craig
colonel minerva eternals
i mean it would be great i feel like
i feel like that would be the one
franchise i would love to do a
background extra working as a marvel
film
not like guardians or something i want
to be an extra in wakanda
i meant the mcu franchise
i want to be an extraordinary yeah man
the one guy the token white guy oh my
god
he's not martin freeman oh that would be
that would be a great one to be a part
of mcu can't extra
i don't know man like it always sounds
cool in theory
but honestly like this is this is like
the biggest first world
problem ever that i'm ever going to
complain about right here okay this is
like the what i'm going to do on a
charity live stream
is complain about a first roll problem
when we go to press readings
they're always so far and i can't stand
it
because you have to wait forever and you
get horrible states and they always
start late but they try to get there so
early
what's my point with this oh yeah being
an extra
always sounds cooler in theory than it
is when you actually do it
you know yeah because like the problem
is you are
in in a place on the totem pole where if
that day on set is not going quite
according to plan you're going to be
there
waiting and it's it'll be charming i'm
sure but it'll also be a little more
than you realize yeah exactly yeah maybe
a little more and a little less than you
realized um
let's see here guys see let's see daniel
daniel96j1 thank you so much just for
the
tip just for the donation 60 donation
thank you so much very much appreciate
it thank you dude
anissa uh she says
i love that thank you for your 10
donation anissa i love that you all are
that you all are doing this we all
should be teaching kindness and
compassion
instead of all this hatred and violence
2020 is becoming the year of change that
we needed for a very long time
black lives matter absolutely what i'm
what i'm really hoping this year becomes
is
the biggest slingshot or pendulum swing
we've seen in america
or else we're on track with the roman
empire in a lot of ways
it's like we've got so many horrible
things that have been happening here
and i feel like there can be something
beautiful like it's already great that
the world is united
uh so much of the world i can't say
everybody that's for sure but the world
has unite
so much of the world's united for this
cause right now and i'm i'm hoping that
with all the horrible things that have
happened that we'll just have this
slingshot effect where we just go into
this whole other category of like
greatness eventually
you know like we're gonna deal with a
lot of hard and dark and terrible things
this year
but then hopefully we start going into
this area where
we experience the opposite like some
people my
if you have to boil down the basics of
my spiritual beliefs
i don't out of any of the things i talk
about i don't really talk about my
spiritual beliefs that often
have to boil it down i believe life is
mainly about experience
so to experience you know good things
you have to
like you usually have to experience the
opposite of something to understand
its counterpart so that's what i'm kind
of hoping we have with
all everything's been going on this year
we have a slingshot effect yeah
with something else but you know like
i'm glad the world's uniting because
this
is a this is a worldwide issue it is
it's a worldwide issue
and you know we've got two america is
not the only part of the world
as a lot of you guys in this stream are
from other parts of the world so i think
it's
i think it's [ __ ] grand we're working
together right now people across the
world are joining in and that's
you know that's the thing where it's
that is the most inspiring thing i guess
is just to see so many people again
is where like kovid had us all paying
attention to the same thing
but in a kind of helpless grim way and
in a way i feel like this is a
counterweight because
while covet is completely out of our
hands minus you know the scientists who
are working to crack it
this issue is entirely in hands as
people as communities and everything and
and yeah the the thing is nowadays with
the cell phone the way it is and the
camera's the way they are i feel like
that is the crucial
difference maker like i don't know
exactly how much progress this is going
to
uh tangibly lead to because every state
you know every country is in a different
place
in this progress but uh yeah i mean
nowadays you can see it all
it's it shouldn't have taken all this
but now you know you can
see what's happening from multiple
angles everyone's posting everyone's
documenting we live in an archive
yeah so uh you know even the boldface
lies that come out from you know our
our leaders here who don't seem to even
respect us enough to
be truthful about things they did on
live television you know
i think uh yeah it is it is an
interesting time and more than ever
i think the people of the world the
citizens of the world not the
government leaders and stuff but the
citizens of the world are realizing that
we are all pretty similar you know
regardless of the [ __ ] they're doing
upstairs
yeah um so yeah i i i am always a little
wary because i'm like you know we got to
stay at it and
you know we'll see how much change but
you know you see things happening
already and that's really inspiring so
i i yeah i hope this continues the world
can't go back to normal i mean we need
we need to keep growing we need to keep
the momentum going this can't
ever become like this old news or
yesterday's i mean
maybe one day in a good way you know
or like we've moved past it but this is
not something that will just
like change right away you know because
it's a big conversation that we all like
even those of us who are are tolerant or
who have grown up in a way where we're
open to everybody and
we don't mean to be racist even if we do
something like that
i feel like that conversation is so
nuanced that that's
kind of where we're at right now is
we're all gonna have to collectively
come together and figure out what to do
about
race in general just because yeah like
everybody's at a different place on how
to talk about it and how to engage with
it and that's one of the most important
things right now is us
all learning the situation and coming to
some kind of same page we can talk on
well
it's what's angering me what's
the strange part about one of the many
strange things is happening
during protests and so much of this is
against police brutality
and yet you're seeing so much police
brutality during peaceful protests
yeah like full on and
cops who really don't think they're
being recorded and uh
capturing so much of it i mean i've seen
camera
i've seen cops who know they're being
recorded just mace those cameras and
stuff oh god
you saw that old guy get pushed down
right oh of course yeah and then
immediately into the camera just
it's it's it's some of it is bold bold
face and
and yeah it's weird because it's
inspiring to see communities where
there's a dialogue happening there
between the people and
the law enforcement and stuff but there
is still obviously
way too much poison in the system i just
yeah i never wanted to resort to
something like after with this movement
happening where it's like
we get to a point where like well i mean
yeah it's a problem but it is what it is
you know we can't be we can't just stay
there that's we have to keep
we have to what oh sorry artemis i think
summed it up right there and i've i've
been hearing this quote yeah more and
more
this past week is it's not enough to be
not racist
you have to be anti-rate you have to be
scared to be anti-racist if you are
not if you're against racism like you
should be afraid
and then you realize that if you are
scared to express
you know anti-racism you should take a
look at what the power structure is like
where you are
you know it's like and honestly you know
talking about something like this on a
youtube
live stream no less but on youtube
videos you know
it can honestly you just see the racism
come out of the woodwork oh yeah because
people yeah
you can name yourself anything and no
one will know yeah
exactly so um and somebody's like to
instigate too
anyway uh daniel 96j1 donated some more
thank you buddy embrace your geekness
thank you so much for donating dude
uh he says thanks you guys thanks for
what you guys are doing
what movies do you love that tend to be
despised
by others oh that's an easy one for me
that's an easy one for me wild wild west
yeah baby [ __ ] yeah that's a funny movie
i don't care what anyone says that's
[ __ ] funny that's funny
i have nostalgia for while we west uh
every rob zombie movie that isn't the
devil's rejects
and uh all of the human centipedes maybe
not three so much
yeah you don't mess with the zohan
there's got to be more i feel like i
probably like more hated movies than you
do
yes yeah that is objectively true yes
you do
you like cats i why didn't you say i
really enjoyed it he genuinely liked not
because he thought it was so bad it's
good
he was like well i think i get it yeah i
think i do i mean the thing is
there it is inexplicable and it is weird
and and i won't necessarily say it's
objectively good
but i got a different experience than i
do out of things i go to because they're
so bad it's good
yes and i was like yeah from what i've
been told about cats
that's cats but uh yeah
go treat yourself uh you know idris elba
the cavity
looking naked uh daniel 96j1
is saying uh joseph gordon-levitt plays
the alien on the kanto bite beach in the
last show
okay so she was like i was thinking i
i don't know if i've heard that before
definitely not that's to a specific t
but i was thinking to myself like wait a
minute though joseph gordon
he might have cameo from last jedi in
that canto bike it just seems like a
scene where there'd probably be a
celebrity cameo you know
and uh yeah that's where my mind
concluded yeah
but anyway guys uh if you're just tuning
in gotta repeat this every once in a
while just to be
safe uh or you know because
people are new um what was i going to
say john
if you are just tuning in feel free to
super chat if
that's your preferred method however if
you uh
would be most encouraged if you go to
stream labs because
youtube takes 30 to 40 percent of super
chats
so the uh and normally like when we do
our live streams regular this is our
first time using stream labs like our
intention with this one today
was we want to make sure that like
because we put all earnings assets
included towards
um towards uh towards charity
but we wanted to make sure that as much
of what you guys are donating is
actually going to charity so streamlabs
is a
safer bet for such an occasion it's more
more qualitative for this purpose
especially
and uh make sure to uh hit the like
button if you're here so more people
know about the stream
smash it and all right here we go
controversial
hitman houston says controversial
opinion
john mullaney is the greatest comedian
ever lenny bruce and richard pryor
could never that is a controversial as a
hot that's a flaming hot tape
i don't think i can agree with you i
mean i think john mulaney is a [ __ ]
hilarious comedian
my favorite comedian i i think the one
who is the best
um and i saw his latest stand-up special
and i thought it was [ __ ] funny
and it got a lot of flack on rotten
tomatoes but i would say it's dave
chappelle oh okay
what did you think let me see
i was like oh this is a bad day for that
dude no [ __ ] uh
dave dave chappelle like i i even i
thought
he's prolific man i am one of those i
have a pin tweet on twitter that says
like if you actually look up what it
means to be woke
um i don't i feel like if you're against
that you would you
it would say more about you than it does
about those who are
actually woke and uh so i identify as
someone
in that category wokeness is something
that you work on
that doesn't mean woke equals cancel
culture i want that to be clear too
all right that's the problem yeah that's
the problem we always lump
everyone into one category protesters
they're all looters and rioters and
you know the tricky thing about
terminology is yeah
sometimes there are purposes you have to
read into and uh
it makes things some somewhat confusing
yeah
but you know um but if people really are
so tense don't say billboard
yeah no i like it's but like i love
i love the buttons that dave chavel
pushes and it's just crazy to think that
in if i'm going to use the term cancel
culture to think in
this time that he would do that
stand up and he's still around no
problem
well i'm just gonna show you how great
he is this man
and the image he's built for himself
he's so [ __ ] funny i
i think within cancel culture we are
getting to a point where
it's weird it's like when somebody does
something truly heinous yes we we cancel
them but
i feel like there's an initial out if
somebody just has an antiquated point of
view or expresses
poorly or something like that i feel
like there's an initial outcry for
cancellation
and then depending on the uh you know
response they'll lose some folks but
you know we i feel like there is a line
made
inevitably even if people are calling
for cancellation
if it's not like that type of offense
you know you'll you'll be fine fair
enough fair enough all right john can i
do
i do think people got to be able to
learn and grow can we pull back up the
uh this one here thank you johnny let's
let's
do that i appreciate it man yeah i
appreciate it you going back up top
nah scoop it at the bottom it's cool all
right
let me have this guy so
isa multi-fandomed
best horror movies of the last decade
hereditary horror movies at the last
decade horror
movies motion pictures or films
or cinematic experiences
god in in any particular order ones that
come to mind
i mean i i well in the spirit of the day
god name check jordan peele because like
get out and
uh uh us are both great both landmarks
for
the decade i would say babadook is a
movie i really love your duty
well i don't know i mean that's right
that's why i did that
i like us more than get out i do i i i
find yeah like i really like get out i'm
looking up a release i'm not just
texting i'm looking up a release date on
uh oh no it's not in the decade
uh i was gonna say drag me to hell it's
on the deck oh yeah 2009 yeah
uh yeah i know i probably would agree
like i love get out but
us is so much more strange and out there
and
and
it has different kinds of layers yeah so
uh i would definitely throw that in
there i think green room is terrific
um they're really intense uh
what are some of the other
yeah i would say babadook hereditary um
god other horror movies like a couple of
remakes i really liked were the crazies
and maniac
i really liked uh the witch
the witch is great yeah i like the witch
a lot uh
the lighthouse is not really there
that's scary
horror movie i mean mid-summer for that
for that
for that matter is it woodens and city
has come out
oh those are those yeah those are 2010s
right well yeah first in city is like
2010.
insidious i would say or uh [ __ ] uh
conjuring but i would say i'm more of an
insidious james juan
james wan movies generally speaking
oh yeah don't fetty alvarez man and i
liked his evil dead a lot too
oh oh my god mimi i'm talking about the
hannah gatsby new stand-up that's a good
one too
oh i gotta see i gotta see she's got
another one out i think
yeah that's the one i just watched oh
good it's good yeah all right
we ever stream on twitch what do we do i
mean are people just using twitch now
just to stream like they're like you
don't have to be a person who's doing
let's plays and [ __ ]
i think you can that's what uh yeah i
think you can i don't know exactly did
ben was on ben goddard was on twitch
okay
um but i would play games on twitch like
i would i would
i wouldn't do it in a way where it's
like this is like a dedic
you know like an hour a week or
something like that get on and play a
game and screw up a lot i would do that
that sounds like fun
and i would also say it chapter one is
one of the best horror movies of the
decade
i would say chapter one landmark i'll
give it yeah
i don't want chapter two but that's a
chapter one is i don't love it
to that degree but i will yeah i think
it's worth the mention because that's
like
i think the conjuring in the 2010s
really made for the return
of you know respected blockbuster horror
and that movie is another kind of
uh uh representation of that to me so in
terms of blockbuster big budget huge
event horror movie i think yeah it is
definitely a landmark
oh we should okay i think we should just
eventually move to twitch
not just the channel i'm talking about
like you know
we should do a live stream that's with
twitch uh oh we got some more here in
our uh
okay let's go john can you move yes move
the super chat away
yes get rid of these get rid of the
super chats
all right here we go who do we got here
on uh stream labs we got
uh soul skier 1999.
love the show and what you do guys power
to the movement what was the first movie
you saw
in the cinema mine was babe two
mine was babe uh yeah and mine was babe
too big in the city
i mean maybe for me i don't know
i'm trying to think back like i probably
don't remember what my first
real movie theater experience was maybe
it was like the mask or something
mine what i know exactly what mine was
oh well let's hear it
i got a good one oh i got a good first
i got a great first minute yeah not one
i got a great one i've got a [ __ ] one
like yours
yeah oh mask 1996
94 94
yes so the mask is probably because i
would have been yeah i would have been
very very young at the time
i got i'm going to give you a hint john
of what my first movie
experi movie theater experience scent of
a woman no
no sea of love
it was oh oh dice did he got it
have you heard me say it before oh
jurassic i was gonna go
were you traumatized or were you yeah
i was very scared i was screaming my
head off the scary ass movie
harry has the scariest version for a
three-year-old yeah yeah
scary ass [ __ ] movie it's weird i
feel like i i really remember watching
jurassic park when i was at the age
where you're just like cool
dinosaurs and stuff yeah but uh it
wasn't so i
saw it again as a more adult aged person
where i was like oh this is a horror
movie with monster right yeah
i'm sorry for you i love whenever
joe keith just came in the chat and i
love when he's
whenever people say hello there all i
hear is obi-wan kenobi going hello then
every time someone says that uh thank
you rachel
um yep guys all right what's next harry
potter was not it
all right here we go there you go who
knocked on the stream
is a bit quieter john did you believe
something i didn't
um but we can you know futz with it guys
look when in doubt blame john we can
crank you a little bit
it's also uh simple this may be uh
coming to you
stereo as well so if you are only
wearing a one headphone
try that too um yeah because sometimes
it'll mix it so that i'm
literally on the left channel and you're
on the right channel so
there are people here who uh definitely
saw jurassic park way too early
i think like that was a rite of passage
in the early 90s was to see
jurassic park too early for for that
generation anyway for
our general i think people are surprised
by how scary jurassic park is hey black
chocolate welcome to the stream
love to eat you up dude
me some really my favorite chocolate is
dark chocolate
yes like i always reels even if you have
reese's peanut butter cup dark chocolate
is so much better
i've that's the candy i'm so glad they
make all these candies with a dark
chocolate alternative because that's
where it's at
hashtag it's john's fault
does that create any drama for you i
haven't
haven't heard that since so oh my god
back in the day back in the olden times
of elementary sorry to start this did it
pop up with a hashtag and this is now
always that i'm sorry josh it's okay
you're bringing back a
childhood memory i even remember this
from god's fault from fourth grade or
something right he's like fourth grade
yeah we we had a friend his name was
jared and he would uh yeah there was
just became this
joke that everything was every like
interruption
or you know misfortune in class would
just be my fault
and he would uh you know among other
things throw that at me everything that
would happen he goes john's paul always
got a big lap but it wasn't nice on john
he was he felt really belittled but it
was funny
i'm sorry john it's okay i feel both i
feel how terrible and traumatizing that
was for you to get publicly bullied
with this john's fault thing in a grade
of the same kids who would always laugh
at you
it's compassionate it's also really
funny
yeah i mean nowaday like that that i'm
not like
oh god no yeah now i think it's funny
in hindsight okay here we go
who's next rach rachel from brooklyn
brook brooklyn brooklyn brooklyn
released the alba cut
of what of all the youtube
it's just me stepping into every movie
going see that fault it was john's fault
um let's see here she rachel
um i wonder if you're in the protest uh
thank you black chocolate i appreciate
it what if black chocolate say
john's life matters now that
is that's not a response but thank you
have you heard that michael chabot
there's a great michael chabit that's
that's floating around the internet
right now about like
it's just matters like it's black lives
they matter
it's not like they're the most you know
it's just that we matter
well that's the problem that i think
comes up with the all lives matter thing
is like no one's saying all lives don't
matter all lives matter
is literally the point to show you that
it's not
that's that way
[Music]
this is focusing on discrimination
police brutality
against black people and like there's
it's a very specific movement
but for some reason some people might be
taken into an account of like
of like oh dude no all lives
do that with everything in your anytime
you hear a problem just go
oh yeah well what about like dude no
it's no one's saying that
yeah and i mean i think it's really easy
to get no one's saying only
yeah and really uncomfortable about this
topic
for sure and uh uh the when you watch a
video of a man knocking an
arrow at a crowd of people shouting all
lives matter it
it really isn't the point you're really
missing the point like you're about to
missing the point shooting everybody in
an arcade
like it's i'm glad you didn't bring a
gun but also like you're about to
shoot someone with an arrow which is
like somehow
more savage i don't know so yeah
with that in mind i do think it would be
very funny if someone went to a protest
oh no i don't know and
and uh not to mock the there would have
to be someone who's just
like really a dumbass it's like so dumb
that you just can't help but laugh
like the instagram influencer who they
caught
did you see this my girlfriend showed me
i think double toasted did a video about
all i saw was the double toasted title
of it
yeah with the girl who's like can you
take a photo of me as if i'm like
helping out
with what does she have like a drill in
her hand yeah
and then she just thank you and she gets
in her car and she wasn't actually
helping out but she's posting on
instagram as if she's like doing all
this work like like that [ __ ] was so
dumb that it like
and that's the thing is is you know
times are fascinating when
it's like that seems like it should have
been in a mic judge movie or some [ __ ]
like
so i think it would be funny as [ __ ]
if there was someone who went to a
protest
everyone's saying john lives matter
someone just looking so personal
like some white guy
all lives matter he's like
yeah well [ __ ] glenn's life matters
to you
i was like who's dave i'm dead yeah my
life matters too
no one's saying your life doesn't matter
dave actually actually because
because unpacking white privilege and
the concept of that is very
hard uh i think i saw an articulation
of it that that was really great and i
think hits on what happens what what
jerks people's knees defensively
is that it's to say that uh just because
you're white doesn't mean that your life
hasn't
been hard and that you haven't
experienced hardships it's just that
they're not about the color of your skin
and you're exempt from those
and so yeah i think a lot of people
probably have
this and it's what upsets me so much
about trump because i have a feeling
that like half the people who really
idolize him
like there's a lot of things that are
telling me about it yeah he doesn't yeah
it's like you
i bet if you met him and you really
spent some time with him it would become
apparent that he doesn't actually care
about you
yeah and so yeah um yeah i know
i thought that was a good articulation
follow anonymous on twitter
i'm sorry we've been trying to get to
these questions here so much
who is this [ __ ] guy he's here he's
out for himself
you know all right guys so if you're
just joining in
sorry to repeat this again for everyone
who's been here the whole time but gotta
say it because people come in and out of
the stream
um first off hit that like button
secondly
um if you guys uh ever all proceeds are
going to charity
um if you do want to do like a super
chat that's that's fine but
the preferred method would be through
streamlabs
because stream labs youtube youtube
superchats take 35 to 40
of all things that are submitted stream
labs uh
i don't know the percentage but i know
it's definitely not as
high thank you as um as
uh as what youtube takes so more money
will go to the charity in and of itself
yeah um because like
to put it in a nutshell there are there
are ways that these platforms do
just directly donate and and take care
of the fees
but they're a select few they're a very
select pool
uh that you can do that with yeah and it
didn't include this
so john just said say john's life
matters
jeter even said it so i'm i'm um i
appreciate you all
i'm i'm glad that i'm glad thank you i'm
glad to matter
rachel what's your question i'm so sorry
um she says hey guys i'm a big fan
it really uh warms my heart to see you
doing this
been a huge fan for a long time sending
love from nyc well thank you rachel
love right back to nyc i saw those
photos of you guys marching that was
another hot zone over there spiderman
jesus man jesus um
guys yeah i mean i've been i've been up
since like 7 a.m
because of filming for my cat from hell
16 hour days slider you have a great
night buddy um
jerry's life matters too okay
so uh rachel jurassic room back here
hey jurassic group um he's donated
again do you guys have a favorite movie
or miscellaneous media monster
also thoughts and prayers for the people
of hong kong
for sure what is is there a is there a
new development
that i've missed yes
okay we know everything
well i mean there's been protesting
going on there for quite some time
and you know the outbreak of coven 19
and whatnot so i
news updates really did yeah the thing
is
like i like to uh you know snapshots
around town
guys inform us on what's going on in
hong kong yeah i i
no yeah seriously because i would like
to know and yeah definitely i mean
if there's more than thoughts and
prayers also yeah
but uh yeah love to the people in hong
kong because it's been tough there for a
while
um um but yeah thank you uh what was the
question favorite movie or miscellaneous
media monster
um ooh i mean the thing is probably my
favorite movie monster
it's really hard to top the thing why'd
you go for a sam trick-or-treat
got it boom oh hey good cow
i love mr babadook partly because of the
like
weird silent film german expressionist
vibe that comes with that and uh
i'm trying to think is there like a i
would say in recent years
baba yaga from hellboy that was a good
one yeah it was a great one
and that movie was good too
there are
what do you guys want john to say john
john lives matters
john's john lives
the lives people should go
john's lives matter movement would have
to be
some kind of rights movement for the
clients of sex workers it's the only
thing that would work
like john doesn't say the will smith
genie oh [ __ ] yeah
um hitman houston neil brennan is
funnier than dave chappelle
that's remember neil brennan so i can't
argue with you on that but thank you for
your donation dude
neil brennan is sharp i would i would
love to do a side by side
i love he's sharp he's fine i mean he
and dave chappelle have worked really
closely together a lot
so a [ __ ] furious gamer hashtag
greg's life
matters question mark
yeah all things matter all names do
matter
yeah it's the least you can do to learn
somebody's name oh
god there's gotta be a sketch of like
idiots doing the things
yeah well there are a ton of great
illustrations of of
the the backwardness of the argument
dynamic
all right john what is um what
what do you guys want john to say john's
first there was ellen degeneres now it's
john's life
these are going to become t-shirts at
some point uh that's what we want you to
say john john say
you are loved you are special and you're
unique i am loved i am special and i am
unique
oh is this from that video of the little
girl doing the affirmations
i saw a little a a video of a mom and
her daughter
and a little girl said she was like i'm
ugly and then her mom
was like yeah it was just one of those
really beautiful things where she's like
don't ever say that you're beautiful and
then the girl starts crying because it's
such a beautiful moment
anyway all right if it's not a reference
sorry all right so then we got here eric
horseman back on stream labs
forget the cats elo watch save by the
barn on animal planet just rewatch
insidious and sinister which
is creepier in your opinion john you
take that one away
okay um first of all saved by the barn
is this is this like a a high school
sitcom
with animals because if it's anything
like what it's referencing i want to see
it's on an animal planet
it can still be like saved by the bell i
think it is man i'm pretty sure you've
seen the history channel lately
and what they qualify as the name of
their channel it's the animal flash i'm
not sure
all right well anyway wait wait wait
wait are you the one going on animal
planets my cat from hell
or is it me i'm sorry everyone's gonna
go john's
i would say you know what i think
sinister is
creepier i might say that insidious
is scarier in the way where it'll like
make you jump and squirm
but there are some images in sinister
that are really chilling especially in
the eight millimeter footage that they
shot and there are some
some really breathtakingly disturbing
moments there so
uh i'd say insidious is the more fun
bouncier
you know more wild movie but uh sinister
i think is really
eerie and creepy that's fair yeah
all right here we go life matters john
agree we've definitely raised more money
than you know any live stream we've ever
done before which is a [ __ ]
amazing thing yeah bailiff project 25
it's probably going to be going up the
bailiff one too um
hillary cat's lives matter greg's castle
i've definitely [ __ ] matter
uh hillary b i'm not wow that's a crazy
thing to hear about what's happening
hillary b i've never i i don't know
anything about that story
i'm definitely gonna look into it where
are you from hillary remind me about
that
um jesus christ what the [ __ ] that's a
crazy story
i just found the comment you're reading
wow
yeah even minds are fast i can't listen
to too many like true
michael b in the chats yeah but but uh
human minds are fascinating
i'm sorry about that eric oh my goodness
okay i mean i already got hillary sorry
uh all right
do you hear carol baskin is getting
jokes yeah she's getting the joe exotic
zoom
why where all the hot [ __ ] from three
years ago what harley said
well they are um they're warranting
right now they're home right now yeah go
look up their various
pictures support those show them love
and uh when we can safely do things
again
we'll let you know all right so here we
at okay john can we go to the uh
don't tell me that it didn't happen
have you seen that have you seen that
song well you're missing out
okay here we go got the box back who's
next
all righty we got we got
kartik sharma hashtag it's john's fault
rick mcclain rambo are the what fixers
they said funeral like jesus christ uh
wick mclean rambo are the fixers
okay so that's like your trio to get the
[ __ ] so
john humphreys the villain that uh that
forces
john wick john mcclane and john oh wait
a minute
clean up my mess oh cause there are
other johns yeah
yeah yeah yeah it took me getting to
rambo's name on the third
go around and go they're all john's yeah
we'll throw john cramer in there because
jigsaw is teaching people how to live
yeah i'll hang out with all these johns
and john david washington as well
john david washington wait gay weirdly
enough
black clansmen is the movie i've seen
the most times since it came out
yeah like it's on tv a lot and i that's
the [ __ ] adam driver right that adam
driver
and um you know that other supporting
white cop
the racist characters oh my goodness
i wonder what it's like for people in in
that position where you're working on a
movie that is directly commenting on and
interacting with a situation like this
and you're brought in to play
you know suit like a super racist vile
character it's a bunch of people who
really didn't realize that they were
going on a film set
they signed up for a camera [ __ ]
oh no
um here we go where is he this would be
the time i feel like if sasha baron
conan waited
a minute to come back this would be the
time bernie alvarado
hi greg hi bernie
how are you bernie good luck on my cat
from hell cats and men well
well i'm telling you it's been up
you'll see it's in a week the only
problem i have my cat
is that he opens every cabinet and eats
anything he smells he says i will say hi
so how do you cap for me so how do you
kitty cat for me thank you so much bunny
alvarado i'm so kind to you
that sounds like cat behavior to me it
certainly is
john great way to put it all right guys
uh we'll be signing off shortly i
i wanted this one to go very long today
um 12 hours
who are not those guys uh go check out
our we we guested for an
hour on the double toasted live stream
well
i got more [ __ ] [ __ ] to film for my
cat for now
no did it just hit you
no it's like i'm getting the messages
and stuff but
hey we agreed contract
i didn't realize how i told them i was
i feel like it'll be a good episode for
them and at the end of the day it's like
a minor complaint it's like there's
i don't know we're we're still donating
and we're still we still have our
fundraisers going so this is just
another
implementation to it i just wanted it
but i don't know livestream's just fun
it's [ __ ] fun to do too so i was like
it'd be great to
direct the attention of all the
contributions but so far raised a good
amount of money on this
two hours alone so thank you guys so
much we're close to having raised a
thousand dollars
we'll be here for a little bit longer
just a little bit longer but we'll keep
but if you guys are just tuning in you
can donate super chat uh but if you
the preferred method would be to do it
through streamlabs is on stream labs
um you uh less taken out yes
fees and nonsense that's what it is john
thank you for
let's get in my back there youtube
overhead to pay for it yeah yes ah
john ask the audience a question while i
take a little bit of a breather
okay guys uh what has uplifted you the
most
this week and it's been a tough week and
it's not a week to
uh you know paint over with completely
unrelated nice things but i don't know
it's been a tough week for humanity
everyone's tired i i think of uh uh
we just rewatched the thing in fact
because my dad did a podcast about it
and uh
you know i think back to that put your
mic towards my mouth
your dad was on a podcast yes
your dad seems like the last person to
be in a podcast see since the quarantine
my dad has become a very active member
of uh
he is one of the heads of like a of a
group
of you know assistant directors and
various people
uh in that kind of mode they have a
couple other people in various stations
but uh
they have like these zoom meetings every
week and stuff and they you know
talk about business and and now yeah one
of those guys was doing a podcast i
guess
and uh we got band-aids and my pops
worked on the thing back in the day and
so uh they were able to get a couple
other people on there and uh should be
pretty cool
will this video get demonetized
sexy legs too much legs
is this considered sexual content
favorite question is this considered
sexual content why is the viewer account
going down hello everyone
all right yeah so uh what is yeah what's
what's been making you feel
all right about the world a little bit
or hopeful or whatever
i would people shout now bts
oh my god who's wait who's watsky watsky
freestyle record
okay uh my fan oh anissa's sitting in
the chat my family has lifted me up
uh rizzo saying uh talking with some
elderly customers and we got
talking about our pain and now you know
john glad you asked a really nice
question thanks
um do what i can let's see here seeing
all the countries supporting us and
something that's made me very happy
oh rachel that's a great thing to notice
the thing that is lifting me up
most this time is greg's legs um are you
in your underwear again greg
no no no i go commando on the weekend
meaning i go into the jungle
let's see here oh my god you know what
some some girls
sell photos of their feet oh yeah i'm
gonna sell photos of my legs
peggy's you know what's funny i might
not have a great i have a strong butt
i'm a very strong the first person to
brag that to me i don't have a
big butt you know but i got a firm butt
yeah i don't got that bubble but i don't
have a bow but i got a firm butt though
but don't need it but more than like the
part of my body that i'm most
comfort confident it's actually i do i
have some very
strong legs that's like the weird
part is like a lot of guys go for the
upper body and that's what i work out
more than anything else
but it's my legs i look the best of
don't worry greg's only fans is
definitely coming soon
i'll be my only fan what is his only
fans have all our friends started doing
porn or something what is what is only
fans is it porn
it's like an intimate chat service that
allows you to sign up for
like a certain amount of month and then
you know you get sexy content
because yeah i'm like seeing all these
people and i've never been
only fans i'm like what is this like
everyone on social media there's a woman
who's doing only fan
yeah right now it is like a social
network where you subscribe it's kind of
like sexy patreon
or something like that where you
subscribe but you can you know
purchase little videos or whatever i
think i don't know there's no one i'm a
fan of enough to want to do it and if
it's a girl i know this is [ __ ] weird
to me
like i don't want them no no you know
yeah plus i got a girlfriend that'd be
[ __ ] weird if i did that
i mean i i don't i don't know i mean i
don't know so john stop pressuring me to
get
to subscribe to an only fan sorry i was
like do you have a lot of close friends
who are starting
like like i don't know there are a lot
of like well-known people who have them
too
so uh john you should only fan site
yeah i'll do that i'll get i don't think
sex works sex workers work
you know it's weird if john is also a
lady i would consider it i don't i don't
care as much for this form to do that
well dude you should uh you should uh
should we throw out there that they
donate a certain amount to black lives
matter
you will have sex with if we can get to
five thousand
dollars
everybody's doing it um black choco
congrats on the weight loss oh damn
there's all these comments about my legs
thanks guys yeah people love it um
that's right
that's okay it'll be we'll start a real
rejects only fans
will have pictures of your legs and my
hair no nice there you go
all right where are we at here let's get
focused greg thanks for all the likes
comments said i'm just asking
double monetized thank you says
asmr okay you know asmr is underrated i
i understand the appeal let's get those
super chats back
back at it like a crack addict mr black
magic
all right where we at we have a sticker
oh my god don't we yeah we gotta go to
anissa first okay because anisa says we
all be friends forever
and if so will real rejects go on until
y'all are 90
also would love to watch y'all on twitch
i had if i had a sam to my dean
i should say my brother
[Laughter]
i guess it'd be john
i mean is there another sam and dean
style duo who aren't related
we're like the one guy has a brother who
he's really close to us ooh
will graham and hannibal lecter michael
b is in the chat
if you guys haven't seen the hannibal
show but if you have
you'll know my reference i'm hannibal by
the way
[ __ ] will graham hey man people love
that actor
uh whose name i used to know um
yeah what is it he used to use it for
rhymes a lot that's why i knew it too
and now i can't
but uh yeah i mean um i think we will be
i mean if we're alive till 90 i mean the
way john takes care of his health
i don't put that much craziness into my
body i should take so don't i should add
too much
nutritional stuff you could up the
nutritional intake
i could yeah and i cannot say better i'm
not saying take a bunch of protein or
something like that but you know make
sure to get
the right things for a more longevity
more focused
cognitively function healthy cellular
look john i used to weigh like 50 more
pounds
i learned a thing or two about being
healthy
i'm listening so maybe not only eating
muffins when you're here
during the week could be beneficial for
you yeah
that's fair i had i had a uh egg and
i had like a little egg sausage burrito
i had it egg
i had an egg
cutting down and eating better i forgot
to cook it
i just drink yeah rocky man if it works
for if it's good enough for stallone
oh i'm daddy all right dude speaking of
pride month john gets the ladies i get
the gay guys
and i'm okay with that especially
during june um all right where are we at
but yeah
thank you uh maybe we will get a twitch
and harley hutcheson
uh hey you thank you for your sticker
eric horseman just for the sexy legs
eric charles
love you buddy and uh anissa
hashtag the sexy legs of the real
rejects
in a in a few hours give it a month or
two and then we'll start dropping that
hashtag in
but john is we don't want to cover all
the important information in that
hashtag and then he's the same but john
is like your
your brother isn't he yeah i'd say so
john actually john's actually going to
probably be on my cat for mel
because uh you'll see me in the
background because like normally if you
guys have seen the show what they'll do
is they'll hang
they'll usually have to put like shelves
and [ __ ] but
the um that they give you and normally
they have a crew that does it
but because of quarantine we have to be
the ones who are doing it ourselves and
we couldn't figure out a lot of john
actually
believe it or not he was the handyman in
this situation he's the one who's been
able to figure out how to do all the
proper drilling and how to teach me a
thing or two
so thank you john i publicly thank you
here today
you're working well some of your
masculine skills
hey man i i i can build stuff and then
my ego was hurting and i'm like i gotta
get in there
put a [ __ ] drill in a hole
that's good i'm glad yeah i'm happy we
could share that together
um i always keep forgetting how to
change tires i do it
like when you're when they're guiding me
but i don't always forget how to change
tires
oh anisa shipping out a package thank
you so much
i gave her your home address to your
parents oh good
yeah that way all real rejects fan mail
can go directly to john's parents
yeah they'll appreciate it i mean you
know my dad can't work right now
oh there's there's not a film production
yet
uh hey oh thanks jerry jerry garza i
appreciate that very much
thank you so much for all the donations
you guys have done so far
guys we raised a pretty great amount of
money on this stream right now like i
said 2500
on uh the bail project as well already
uh we're gonna we're gonna sign off in
just a little bit ah damn it
you don't have to simp for me ryan
i know i know you're i know you're a
switch my dude
um but yeah how about this how about
this to make it worth it
um let's go through okay all right well
thank you for that
thank you for that next super chat there
also john i would like to subscribe to
your only fans of wholesome content
haha on john'sonlyfans.com site
um you can see right between
where his falls and butthole are and i'm
hoping jon's parents are watching
everyone go to john's onlyfans.com
yeah and then to bring up another
traumatic moment for john
it's uh hump for free is the handle so
go over there
um i'm telling you guys it'll be well
worth your money
to look at what's that spot called the
gooch go over there today
gooch the taint etc yeah
hey man there there are people who
succeed on these platforms who do
non-nude
who just do what you are i am just
only fully understanding what only
fans.com is as of a few minutes ago but
i don't believe that
well not not just only that like various
work out or something
various online well they'll do either
partial or suggestives or
be there for more the interaction gfe
girlfriend experience
okay so who here who here in the chat
currently um can we take this away just
what do i hit i'm sorry
gonna hit this little eyeball so
speaking of packaging all right
transition so that it applies it to the
stream um
okay who here in the chat
currently has uh uh
um uh [ __ ] uh who who's
who's pledged to like an onlyfans.com
account
and who are you and if you're
comfortable who are you who are you
pledged to is that dude
what
[Music]
like a monthly service right it's like a
patreon before like nudies or something
yeah is that what it is just like nude
pictures yeah yeah
it's literally like like it's it's it's
like a
to the best of my understanding it's
like a combination of
like a private you know okay video photo
stream
but also that has uh it's like a private
social network where you can interact
and sext and stuff
okay we should get an onlyfans.com site
yeah
sure just you and i and it should just
be like us in suits yeah
we're always like just very proper
for this thing from sexual and we we're
just incredibly
yeah we're straight ladies incredibly
respectable we're holding sex
but we're fully dressed
to go out in the cold water should be
very misleading because we should what
we should do
is go on instagram and post
that we are um that like we should post
shirtless
and say check us out on onlyfans.com
but then when they go there it's the
antithesis to it you know
shouts out to 50 50 make wookie rodica
style sensual shirtless pics please
yeah good good thanks for listening to
those giant panda king shout outs
um who's tana mongeau anisa are you
messing with us
okay so here's my question for the only
fans thing
what makes it why would you
go there as opposed to
watching porn or going to
is the best charity stream ever or
stuff doesn't get talked about or uh sex
work is real okay yeah why would you go
to onlyfans.com
as opposed to watching porn or um
you know [ __ ] like going on a what
are those called the webcam chats
uh if you get like the internet like
what's the difference there is this the
personal touch
i mean a webcam chat's pretty personal
isn't it yeah yeah i mean i don't think
it would pro
as a business model i can see the allure
of it from the creator side because what
i would imagine is hard for cam models
is that there's no base pay so
you have to hope that people tip or take
you for a show or something
uh and on only a few desperation that's
why
for some people i'm sure but for some
people that's just the way to make a
living
okay so next work is work so is it like
there's like those instagram models
right who who are like who like i don't
do porn i don't do that but then maybe
on the only fans now that are actually
being new is that kind of what
i'm trying to understand what this is
yeah i mean i assume there's a lot of
porn there is probably and it goes to
support the person okay
yeah yeah it's like a direct you pay
whatever a month and and yeah it is like
kind of like patreon instead of
like the youtube of porn would be a
campsite where it's like or or
pornhub words like okay i hope enough
tips come in or ads come in that i get
paid or something whereas and only fans
is like okay
at least someone's going to pay me for a
month and then maybe there's
you know you can pay for other premium
stuff inside
but yeah i get the sense it's just
another means of the personal touch
okay there's mixed
some people here seem to be speaking the
dialogue you have and some people are
like it's just poor
like that's the i feel like that's maybe
that in ways it is porn
this is a private subscription social
judas only because
hey 50 50 got the gotham book hell yeah
got them oh nice that is that's a great
rather than two days love the [ __ ] out
of that great
love i would i would that's the kind of
stuff i would love to see
come to the big screen man okay um all
right let's do the last round of
questions here
but thank you guys so much for being
here um keep a lookout for the upcoming
uh community tab
post so so this guy is literally using
only fans instead of patreon
is is what time fascinating monjo is
doing interesting
okay i i mean because that's the thing
is oh and then yeah you're also not paid
well
on like from doing actual porn so this
is a great way to get direct money
because i think they only take
eighty percent only take no no i i think
i think twenty percent eighty percent
yeah yeah yeah i mean i i have to admit
like that
it's got to be fascinating to watch this
industry grow because it's you know an
industry that doesn't get respect anyway
but um but there's so many new avenues
and there's so many ways for people to
take the work into their own
hands now and to make it their own
hustle and to
change what the system looks like so i
find that fascinating
okay so you don't just all right so it's
kind of like a
it's something more akin to like a
patreon page yeah
got it okay and there are there are
people who do
this kind of thing via patreon right
right yeah or some people who just do
uh uh you know art photography that
happens to include nudity or something
like that they'll put up like here's a
sensor version on instagram ah cause the
uncensored version on only fans or
it's a patreon whatever daniel uh 96j1
thank you so much for donating another
twenty dollars via streamlabs so much
and then uh john
can you pull this uh super chat we are
we
i think we are getting close to breaking
a thousand dollars on this stream
yeah that's great awesome guys thank you
so much for participating
we want to get the super chats back yeah
let's do that let's do that
i'm trying to make sure i'm like [ __ ]
oh god god damn
[ __ ] is it is it your brother no
wondering why
you're not his dean or sam all right
oh harley hudson thank you so much for
your support my dear with the sticker
you sent
and kartik sharma john
read it please guy wore shorts on hot
day to
office boss threatened to fire him for
violating mail staff
dress code he came back wearing his
girlfriend's dress allowed under the
female dress code and freedom for gender
expression
and then there's like a side wait i
don't get it wait guy wore shorts
on hot okay tell me so this guy wore
shorts to his office on a hot day and
they were like
shorts that's not in our dress code you
can't wear that you gotta put on some
stuff that's in our dress codes the guy
looked at the dress code and was like
women are allowed to wear
dresses that's in the dress code i'll
just come in and address instead
and i've actually heard of this
happening before and did he get fired of
years i don't know uh uh did kartik
comment did this person retain their
employment because i've i heard a story
like that like a decade or more ago
about yeah like
workers outside even who are like yeah
they won't let us wear shorts we all
came in in skirts
and and jesus christ they did their work
and it was fine and it was like we're
just going to use this loophole because
this is dumb
stuck yeah
stuff like that that's a great way to
fascinating i once cooked in my
underwear at the hot dog place that's
still up and which damn merle and
maracanopic have gone to now
yeah because of that story i passed it a
couple times it is not boarded up
so you can get oh really yeah you can
get a hot tub and a greggy veggie
if you guys live in uh california go to
north hollywood get a hot dog named
after me
black chocolate we typically live stream
on saturdays in the
four or five-ish hours sometimes other
days though depending on
extraneous circumstance all right we're
gonna do a speed round of the quest john
let's get rid of this
let's speed round to the questions in
here we raised a good amount of money
today guys
yeah uh thank you guys so much for
contributing and um
this combined with bail project i think
we've done good this week yeah
one week and uh so yeah i think we've
done pretty good and
thank you guys so much because all
proceeds going there
um i mean like it's divided the whale
projects
black lives people found out about only
fans because beyonce
yeah apparently beyonce's been like yeah
i've heard about it from her too and i
was like all right
oh yeah i mean i just didn't know she
she checked it but i'm glad she's pro i
guess
all right man okay okay we got another
one from anissa oh here we go given the
charity anissa
thank you so much this is smart news so
you can get
instead of doing a 50 donation for that
this is the day where it needs
to start although eric i was just
you know holding back because of the
fact that uh a lot
well he dropped a lot a and b
um you know like he might not be able to
go back to work till october at this
point
because yeah it's been some scary stuff
but what did nieces say
lisa has said what do y'all really think
of sam and dean's relationship
also john you should check out jensen's
singing tennessee whiskey by chris
stapleton i will do that mark it down
johnny boy i love it when he
uh does his music thing um screenshot in
it what do i think of sam and dean's
relationship
i feel like the uh tough one i mean
we're i'm kind of scared to dive into
this topic because we're on a live
stream
yeah it's not so much about the opinion
here
it's more about you know
i don't want someone to say something
mariano but yes but everyone should act
that way
yes thus the black lives matter
um i would say that uh they are very
um they're very codependent but they're
also brothers and all they've had is
each other so i respect i feel like
that's the saving grace
they were just two friends that might
have been a different story but because
they're brothers
their relationship makes the most sense
so you got a tough relationship man i'm
always worried for them nowadays and i'm
always sitting here going guys just talk
to each other
yeah just talk to each other um but at
where we are in the show
is giving me hope yeah i'll say that
much
gotta love the sam and dean though guys
this chat is consisting of a wide
variety right now
of only uh what's what the [ __ ] is it
onlyfans.com
and yeah and it's pretty that's mainly
it now
and then greg and john being woke
doing doing our doing our best all right
guys
well we're gonna call it right now can i
can i do one more thing really quick
absolutely i will i did john do you want
whatever you want john
do whatever you want i do want to i want
this to be sincere
so just do whatever you want and we're
here to show our hearts today so please
go right ahead okay
this was the intro for this um yeah do
whatever you want john i just wanted to
shout out our buddy brandon v
because brandon v uh has suffered a
pretty uh
bad loss this week so uh just he's been
a fixture in our chats
and he has been you know very supportive
and
he wasn't aware did it happen yeah
oh geez i'll message him directly yes
i'm sorry about that brendan i thought i
saw your name at some
point and it jogged my memory really
quick and uh yeah just
wanted to throw some love out to you
because uh i'm
feeling for you i'm sorry about that
brendan b i'm just learning directly
right now
much love to you um guys
uh thank you so much message him right
now [ __ ]
all right guys well um no no no it's not
as i'm glad you said that man but
seriously keep brendan v i don't want to
just put it out there what happened
yeah yeah that is a pretty big loss i
was aware of the condition but i thought
it was getting better
yeah i know i did too and then uh yeah
yes you know
so uh he's yeah just y'all who have been
here especially in these streams you've
probably seen brendan around so yeah
send some love out into the universe for
him and his folks
guys i want to say on this note was uh
we're very passionate about
this cause right now and we're doing
whatever we can to be involved
ourselves um already with the fundraiser
we've had this week so much has been
raised and then this is
another additional on top of it uh we're
i'm planning on trying to get more uh
involved in other ways
as well um you know
of course just i would i if you're not
that educated on the situation continue
to be educated on it
and uh don't be afraid to speak out
against
you know don't be afraid to be vocal
with being anti-racist
as well i think that's very important
and
this means a lot that all you got all
you guys donated and
you know what's great is like we
expected
that there'd be dislikes yes like
they're already dislikes coming in
on announcement of it you know like if
you put up this title and there's
dislikes coming in is that we're not
even [ __ ] live yet
so you know you see yeah some people are
just gonna dislike
automatically which is unfortunate which
is indicative of a very
unfortunate state of mind i think and
then there are people who
uh you know it's like i'll see other
channels which
whose audience is pretty clear who the
audience
is by the comments and like there's so
many channels i like like i like the
the youtuber yeah at least their content
but then you see the crowd like oh this
is the crowd
and i'm just happy that
and honestly i've had a lot of people
say like you know your child be bigger
if you tend to more to that audio like a
lot of people have said that
and i don't give a [ __ ] about that i'm
happy that you guys
are for everyone who's been in this chat
and everyone has been donating and to
see
that anytime we do take a moment to
speak about any of these things that you
guys have been so [ __ ] like uh
supportive of the stances that we
take i'm like we're not the people that
go out there and attack woke
crowd or attack you know like the
the things that people focus on during
this peace during this time of
protesting where i'm like
why is your attention like so much time
i hear i'm like why is most of your
attention on
that instead of like hey
the purpose of the protest be the fact
that most of the protests are peaceful
and then
see that there's a literally police
brutality
happening here but you're putting focus
on other things instead around this
yeah it's a form of which are not the
majority of it
so i'm very much grateful um
that this happens to be our crowd that
we've attracted this is the crowd
yeah it's it's i honestly feel like ryan
wright might notice
because i'll play right right was like a
satire of that kind of personality
yeah so um like to be able to make you
uncomfortable
yeah to hit the whole point like i was
thinking about like john boyega like i
remember
[ __ ] uh the first force awakens
trailer
like my whole point of my joke was like
watching the uh like oh stormtrooper
i'm like that's weird never seen a blind
wouldn't imagine a black guy being a
storm trooper
and the whole point was mocking that
yeah you know and then i put it in the
later
and i never when i was doing the ryan
right but i wasn't going out and saying
like i'm mocking it guys and then when i
was saying i was mocking it
i would do another joke on top of that
to mock like
like oh he's not really money monkey you
know um
so in the time of like changing up you
know like being more
getting more comfortable just being greg
on here and of course getting you get a
little nervous when you do a stream like
this
but then it's like you have to get to
that point where you're like [ __ ] it you
know just stand by what you believe in
and to see that most of you guys the
most people who are here at least
care about this this this does matter
this situation is very important it's
important to be educated
and it's beyond politics and if you say
i don't like politics
it's way bigger than that and i forget
who it was who spoke
in atlanta there was a an individual who
was speaking
and he did say and i and this point hit
home so hard
the reason why i think it's important to
direct a lot of attention to the
like redirect it back to the purpose of
the protest the purpose of this movement
point the point of it and the fact that
a lot more
vast majority are peaceful protesters
because i think it is important when
people are retweeting
and talking about engaging with the
the the violent moments of like police
brutality that are occurring
like in our world today before the
protests and during the pro
i think it's very important the thing
that happens sometimes and this and this
individual who was speaking in atlanta
did
what was his name where was this was it
was like press conference and he was a
killer mike
it might have been he gave it yeah
definitely any speech been going and
he's
and he said that like uh i saw with the
date that night it came out and
and he did say like we have a habit of
turning this into murder porn
and just don't let it go there
get a full on don't make it a geek get
it full-on information
about it okay like it's important to be
aware of that obviously
that's what a big part of this
protesting is
and it's important to retweet those kind
of things but i think it's also very
important to get educated on
everything all around and just keep your
eyes open and pay attention and
be open to new perspectives and new
points of view because a big part
especially for allies
who you know haven't had some of these
experiences a big part
of our job is to familiarize and to
learn
things and uh friendly reminder that
it's not up to your black friends to
teach you this
and maybe a lot of people i've noticed
are
tired and outraged and feeling a lot of
things uh
and some people are feeling those things
for the for maybe the first time or or
in a more intense way than ever
and some people have been feeling this
all their life so
yeah so yeah i think especially for the
white folks out there this
it can be tricky to know how best to
approach the situation but yeah
listen elevate the voices around you
you know check in on your friends and
stuff like that and uh
yeah you know it's there's a lot that
you can do
and there's stuff that's you know
directly political you can get on the
street you can sign petitions you can
just share the names and identities of
the people who have been
taken too soon you know it's way too
many
um you know i i hope that people yeah
can fill and really grab the humanity
aspect of this because that's what it's
about you know
no i'm 100 in agreement with you like
this
when i when i went to the protest
on uh on sunday and
uh give me a second
when i went to the protest on sunday
and then there were people like i i
wasn't really aware
of the when people like what you know
you hear
you hear the the regular chants that are
going around
and then you're hearing people say like
we're chanting i
can't breathe
and then you're like chanting that with
a crowd uh
it's moving it just breaks my heart to
like when you watch
like you know what happened with george
floyd's terrible but it [ __ ] breaks
my heart when you see
what it's like to be in the streets
chanting this right now
yeah yeah and why is it taken why is it
why
does it why does a guy have to be like
choked to death on camera by a police
officer and then now we're in the
streets chanting this
and i i like
i didn't real like i i was my fault for
not being aware like this is like a
common chant that's going around in the
protest when i was there it was really
hitting me and and that's when it really
got to me
like majorly and so yeah i'm
it's this protest is not about me so i'm
trying not to like get all [ __ ]
i'm sorry i've already gotten like very
emotional right now a lot of people are
but i'm just saying like this is really
important
and and as much as people are like
keep your [ __ ] politics out of my
movies and [ __ ] or whatever you guys are
real rejects this
is real for life for people to live
so not as important as it's more
important than movies yeah
like you you you read like there's weird
facts i've been learning
like in regards to like real rejects and
having movies there's weird facts i've
been learning
there's like okay
like if we're talking about like uh
representations of black people in
cinema
i i uh spawn came out in the 90s right
yeah and he has a best friend in that
movie who's a white guy
now in the comics that character is a
black guy
but they didn't want to make that best
friend a black guy because they didn't
want
people thinking it would tend to like a
black
audience the movie if he had a black
best friend as well
like this the movie's not just it's not
well we thought it would only be for
black on and then you do
like black panther because of the
biggest [ __ ] movies of all time you
know
yeah jesus i thought you all like money
include people you might make more money
so like when culture changes
when politics change around in this
world um when everything starts to
change
it's like it's get it gets reflected in
your movies and your television shows
and your forms of entertainment
it all does so this assessment of like
keep politics
out of my movies and [ __ ] or or out of
my movie talk or just respond for
entertainment and escapism
after a certain point it's like you
can't just
ignore it you know well yeah and i feel
like especially with a situation
like the like you know i feel like if we
didn't address
say coven 19 or some other like
something trump's doing or whatever
it doesn't that's political to the point
where it's not why you come here and i
get why we wouldn't talk about something
like that but this
this is a human issue it's it's it's
about all of us and it's more important
than entertainment it's more important
than
it's you shouldn't escape like there's a
certain amount of
uncomfort discomfort that we all need to
engage with right like and the onus is
on us to engage with that
and um yeah it's it's funny i haven't
gotten to
to march i haven't gotten to like be out
in the streets obviously because my my
folks are
at the age where they're at high risk
for covid but i have i i do like to
traverse the town and see
what it's doing and how it's shaping and
i have
in a small way gotten to participate
because they've been
marching through hollywood and they're
doing it on sunset and hollywood
boulevard so for a little while i was
just
in my car because there were cars in the
parade too so i was just
in my car just blasting the horn and
throwing up a fist and
and you know even that unity you know
was able to
to you know people were like people the
crowd
even came more alive when other people
started doing that too and it's like
that energy is there's nothing like that
and i'll never forget like the women's
march back in the day like
i went to that alone at first and like
it's the second you get there
just like yeah the the there's nothing
like
the collective energy of people who are
you know believing in something and
especially something that is empathetic
and something that's passionate and
something that's just about liberty and
it's just about what we should all be
having
and that's the thing about these
protests too is that there is an element
of celebration
at least in some of the ones i've seen i
mean there are ones
where clearly the problem is still very
much at hand but also i mean seeing the
people in hollywood there was so much
life and so much joy i think uh uh
mark ellis put out a nice video and he's
a white guy but you know
he put out it's kind of echoing that
sentiment is like yeah there's
there's so much life and even just being
near it is really
moving and you just feel that human
energy radiation
and and yeah you know it's it's yeah
to me this is one of those issues that
even if we don't focus the channel on it
you have to
confront and address and let people know
where you stand because it's about the
world we've literally fought
wars over these kinds of ideas yes so
um yeah all right guys
well as much as like
that this would probably be the best
time to end this three maybe because
we've been trying
we've been planning on like we have to
end right now um we do got a couple more
donations here that i do want to
acknowledge
sorry what sorry me ma'am the the i
heard just
recently about the selma cast uh uh you
know uh with the i can't breathe sure
yeah
um we're gonna read a couple more we'll
end this off and we'll call it a night
mm-hmm
uh okay and the in the live stream we
got
uh in the super chats jesse mama says hi
guys from nz
hey new zealand what's up buddy there
was a hakka in from the u.s embassy
there
mukbang reviews thanks guys no thank you
for donating buddy
and uh the last one of the day hitman
hudson back here what films do you think
would be better with y'all in them
get out black panther
boys in the hood boys do the right thing
stella got her groove back help
hidden figures what are all the movies
named today
the white jesus movie uh i'm not sure
buddy
i should be in the sequel to morbius
because that'll be the only character i
can cosplay
and uh lana pico lana she's real thank
you so much
thank you for uh donating just now right
before we go off the stream
you're amazing thank you lana all you
guys have been amazing appreciate
everyone here
for uh donating to this cause something
i really do care about
um that we both do and uh you know yeah
get educated
get involved be safe out there if you're
planning on going somewhere tonight
involving one of the peaceful protests
um
and uh yeah just be safe keep getting
educated
please and spread the love all right
guys
i'll see you soon i won't i'll be um
probably tomorrow youtube video yeah
yeah uh on the community post will be
combined we're combining both like
whatever youtube takes their as a
reminder 35 to 40
of the adsense revenue but i'll
screenshot what the earnings are
tomorrow
uh and then on and then also on yeah
we'd be great at dogma
and on stream labs we'll take those
earnings and everything will be
screenshoted and we're combining with
the bail project
fundraiser that we put up this week
which is already at 2 500 so
love you guys thank you so much yeah be
well
be safe be active take care and forget
that
that quote that killer mike said about
strategize you know mobilize
educate you know and if we do the quote
man would that be a great way to end
this
see you guys cheers